foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome welcome everybody to a fantastic
Saturday morning we have done it we have
made it this far it is time to react to
the top 100 to reveal the top 100
artists from the boss fight 3D Community
challenge so many of you guys spent the
last month working so hard on your
renders and today is the big payoff it's
gonna be very exciting we are joined by
an incredible artist uh Mr Rafael
grassetti we will meet him very soon
very soon enough
but first we're gonna let people Pile in
what's up chat everybody's popping off
right now so good to see you guys so
many awesome artists awesome friends
from the community joining us today
thank you guys so much for taking the
time for for really putting all of your
energy into your guys's art over the
last month it means so much you guys did
an incredible job myself and the
moderators combed through all 2 880
renders and every time we do this we're
blown away by all the art that we see
it's it's such a good time this is like
the best time of year for me so thank
you guys so much now
how's this gonna go down what we're
gonna do
um once we get into it we're going to be
taking a look at the top 100 renders of
the
2880 renders
those renders those top 100
um those will that will be the top 100
Montage next week next Saturday there's
going to be a curated top 100 Montage
with music from disasterpiece
um it's going to be incredible I cannot
wait so that's next week
um definitely don't miss that the week
after it's going to be the all renders
Montage so all 2 880 minus the ones that
you know
you know weren't able to follow the
rules and they submitted like a two
frame file minus those ones those will
all be in the all renders Montage it'll
be hours and hours of everyone's boss
fight art so definitely make sure you
guys don't miss that
um now
everyone here on stream the top 100
artists on stream today
you guys are all walking away
with a free t-shirt code from caft so
caft is a Turkish design brand they make
awesome shirts bags pants a bunch of
cool stuff
um so everyone here everyone's art who's
gonna be showing today on top 100 you
guys get a t-shirt code from caft
now when it comes to the top five we got
prizes for you guys as well so first off
we have
caft uh 200 caft rewards for the top
five
um we have in the Perpetual licenses
from Jenga effects that includes
ambergen and all of their future
um all of their future releases right
you guys know Amber Jen you've been
using it throughout the month we also
have uh kit bash 3D is hooking you guys
up with a
cargo subscription and that is their new
service which basically gives you access
to
everything that kit bash has ever made
instead of having to buy individual kits
you guys have access to everything and
you can pull individual assets as needed
and finally for third place uh if you
come in third place you're gonna be
getting some Rococo smart gloves right
make hand and finger tracking super easy
second place is getting a full perform
not the full performance capture bundle
that's gonna be first place second place
is the new smart suit Pro 2 suit all
right so you get that whole suit in
first place gets the whole bundle that's
including the suit the gloves the facial
capture setup all that good stuff
um I don't think I missed anybody I
think I got that all
um so just to let you guys know that's
what's going down
we're gonna let you guys Pile in here
looks like we got 1600 people in chat
thank you guys for joining us
speaking of Rococo I'm gonna throw it to
them for just about a minute or so and
when we come back we're gonna meet Mr
Rafael grossetti so I'll see you guys
very very soon don't move them butts
today's boss fight top 100 live stream
is brought to you by Rococo who you know
for their motion capture suits their
smart gloves and their facial capture
technology which a few of you guys will
be walking away with by the end of this
stream and we also know them for Rococo
video the free to use no suit needed
browser based motion capture solution
but two days ago Rococo pushed the AI
motion capture game to the next level by
releasing the all-new dual camera
version of Rococo video called Rococo
Vision two cameras means higher capture
quality better depth perception accurate
ground floor recognition and it also
means no occlusion since your limbs will
be visible from at least one of those
cameras any two combos of cameras are
fair game so you can use a DSLR and a
phone or a phone in a webcam and you
sync them up with these printable QR
codes you can export your data straight
from the browser or use Rococo Studio to
make tweaks add characters and even make
retargeting adjustments which honestly
is huge because my goodness do I hate
retargeting now rococovision is part of
the Rococo plus service meaning it is
240 bucks a year or 20 bucks a month
depending on how you break it down but
they do have a 14-day free trial where
cocovision is out right now I got a link
Down Below in the description for you
guys to get that 14 day free trial going
while we gear up for our top 100 Runners
we're about to get into but without
further Ado let's meet our guest judge
all right figure it out done what's up
Brad how you doing I'm doing good man
there's always something you know I
always like honestly it'd be weird if
there wasn't a glitch like then I'd be
then I'd be truly scared yeah yeah yeah
everything good man thanks for having me
yeah dude absolutely absolutely yo if
you guys don't know who Raph is at this
point you've been living living under a
rock let me get let me give you guys the
overview so RAF you um so many people
know you from your work on uh Ragnarok
God of War Ragnarok the the latest game
that came out
as an art director you were the lead
character designer for the God of War
2018 reboot
um you're currently at Netflix right now
as an art director working on a brand
new IP for a triple a game like the list
goes on and on you work with DC Marvel
um some of my favorite games Killzone
Mass Effect it's insane dude it's so so
awesome to have you here in such an
honor thank you so much
thank you man thank you yeah I've been
very fortunate to be involved on some
some good projects I know uh it's very
based on luck as well so I appreciate it
it's been a fun Journey so far
how long ago did you start man
oh 20 plus years ago I think I first uh
got in contact with 3D when I was about
17 I'm like 35 35 right now yeah so it's
been a while and I was like I said
fortunate enough to be started working
very young too back in Brazil I'm from
Brazil
um so I started doing a lot of
advertising work 3D animation did a lot
of Animation kind of when I was starting
I wanted to be an animator surprisingly
and uh when zbrush came out I started to
go more into the sculpting side of
things and working in advertising you
just kind of have to do everything so I
did a lot of rendering
a lot of lighting composing and then uh
kind of got myself into games because I
wanted to come to the US and that was
you know you know outside of me just
being a you know a video gamer a gamer
from Young ages like it was a good
opportunity to come uh work for
companies so yeah they ended up bouncing
around just before I came here
absolutely man yeah absolutely I have
some questions from a couple of our
patrons here uh if you have I don't know
maybe a couple minutes here before we
hop in into the top 100 maybe answer
some questions
all right let's do this yeah well yeah
absolutely absolutely so real quick
though from from my my buddy wondrous
he's asking how do you balance personal
and professional projects
out like that's a tough thing for a lot
of us you know yeah I mean especially
yeah I wouldn't start kind of having
kids and and work kind of gets busy too
but I've always tried to to treat my
personal projects as freelance as
professional projects so I'm usually
kind of schedule myself and eat try to
make deliverables for myself and pushing
myself in that way because I feel like
that's the only way you can actually
finish something otherwise you're just
kind of bouncing and that's why I think
challenges are such a good uh a good
thing for for personal projects right
because you have a deadline you have
people that are pushing you it's almost
like you're in a professional
environment I did a lot of challenges
when I was starting uh I don't know if
you remember if you've been around like
the dominance Wars and uh Comic-Con
challenges they're all like more
game-centric challenges but they're
super good to like push
um that's kind of how I try to balance
and I'm the worst on like life work
balance because I tend to focus a lot on
on work and I'm always doing something
um but I definitely like scheduling
myself is something that makes a huge
difference on finishing work yeah I
think we all have that problem
um certainly where we'll start something
we won't finish something and unless you
have that deadline that you set for
yourself put it into your into your
workflow into your schedule then it it's
harder it's less likely that it will
happen so that's very good advice
um we'll get one more here let's see so
this is from Paul he asked like where do
you get your inspiration are you finding
it from games and movies or are you
going on walks and being like Oh my God
you know from a walk or something how do
you find inspiration
um and that's a broad one because I feel
like it's just everywhere I'm very I'm
always watching something like I'll
watch you know a series and I'll just
have to do something I think the trick
though is just to actually start doing
something when you're inspired even if
you're not gonna finish it like having
projects started always keeps me
inspired to like go back and and do
stuff so I'm always in either like a
little Sketchbook or just even writing
notes or writing ideas of like okay I
want to do a
a marine because I watched the Sci-Fi
thing like stuff like that like keeps my
brain going and I'm always when I'm
looking for things to do I know what
what I'm gonna hit as I I think you know
or all of us know when you're thinking
about starting something the process of
getting used to the idea and putting it
on paper and getting reference like you
take a long time just to get going or
try to stream like that as much as
possible
that makes a lot of sense yeah because
it does take a lot of energy to like get
it up and running get all the stuff
going and
I think hopping right into taking the
energy that you feel inside and
translating it outside as quickly as
possible that's like a it'll be like a
boost pad for you to then keep you know
putting out your inspiration uh and
laying down that so that I like that a
lot that's really nice
um
last thing here before we get into the
top 100 you actually have your first
like
uh like self ran Workshop that you
yourself are hosting and that's in
Brazil coming up when is that what are
the dates on that
uh two and
first week of October two and three so
second third of October yeah so it's
coming up one month one month from now
so if you're in Brazil
I I don't know if you have a lot of
Brazilian viewers but I'm sure you do we
are everywhere we're always here
make sure to check it out it's on my
Instagram or uh go to my website yeah in
Sao Paulo so if you're from Sao Paulo
yeah there's a handful of tickets left
um there's a link in the description for
you guys I know some of you guys I know
we got some Brazilian fans here so
definitely check that out if you guys
want to learn what are you teaching
you're doing like character design uh
yeah it'll be uh two days the first day
is like an industry focused uh talk
where we're gonna go I'm just gonna walk
through my experience and break down
like how we build a studio how we build
a project the kind of kind of
information that's hard to find
especially in Brazil I want to try to
bring that over there uh in person only
and then second day is more of a
Hands-On we're gonna do some art talk
about some some past projects
uh there's a there's a lot of artists
that I'm bringing on that are friends of
mine for like a round table so really
trying to bring in for information so it
should be fun heck yeah man absolutely
yeah if you guys check it out handful
tickets left Link in the description but
the time has come
Raff are you ready to take a look at
these top 100
yes I'm very excited all right all right
let's do it let's do it blow my mind
all right here we go first render this
is from Australia uh Doug Wilson
did the loop go in
and
we in
nice yeah pretty cool I love the fish
yeah agreed
it's a really cool like interpretation
of the idea
um oh we're getting ahead of ourselves
come on now come on now
um yeah I love this this is like very
very unique I didn't see another render
like this
um
I thought that story element was there
and not really nice yeah such a cool
idea
I would not expect to see this
yeah the color colors are cool
yeah I dig it kind of got kind of got
like a low poly Vibe I don't know it's
it's tough the bird you know the bird's
feathers are yeah
definitely if the bird was like maybe
having his mouth open or something you
kind of get the action of like the
danger yeah
yeah I think that'll be nice
they got the caustics underneath too
nice nice
good stuff Doug Wilson way to kick it
off man good stuff good stuff from
Australia also from Austria we have
our good friend Robert kautz Edge as we
know him let's take a look oh
you guys with these effects
look at that smoke yeah super sick with
the god rays and stuff
yeah yeah simulated on the actual blades
too sick yeah that's the part to me that
I'm like damn the next level yeah yeah
seriously the render quality is just
insane like Edge always does great work
um this one I just wish I just wish
there were some gunshots like in uh
Matrix two when Morpheus pulls out the
like automatic Glock
I just wish it that would be so cool
like on the glass 100 yeah 100 percent
but yeah this is this is really nice
looks beautiful render quality is nice I
love the action The Slow Mo element it's
nice too
yeah
good stuff super solid Edge Mr Robert
kautz from Australia killing it
congratulations on top 100.
all right uh we got a Brazilian for you
here
let's see well how do you know her name
yeah so we have um no I'm not going off
a name that'd be that'll be the end of
me
um
yeah Brazilian flag in there now we had
them we had him put their country so
um yeah yeah it's cool represent okay
yeah this
is
Brazilian but this is awesome yeah yeah
they'll do the lighting is just
ridiculous here the colors are so good
this is Fabricio by the way Fabrizio
I love that Arc with the spear going up
yeah got the trail on it too it's cool
um really nice use of
of slo-mo yeah go ahead
I was gonna mention the trail like this
is something that that people could
sometimes Miss just that that read right
from like Trails on weapons like it's
such a such a cool thing yeah let's be a
little glare too when it catches the
light I don't know if that's custom but
man looks like it yeah it's such a such
a great touch
dude I didn't realize this is all an
Unreal Engine like I thought it was
pre-rendered or something that obviously
it's rendered a little bit but God dang
God damn this is awesome the destruction
looks pretty clean
yeah yeah agreed and he modeled this uh
this this guy too this boss hero or not
the boss here that's very confusing the
boss yeah
all right you got you got some pluses on
my my notebook then this is like his
model yeah
holy yeah
incredible Fabricio
hats off to you man killer work freaking
killer work as always yeah this is
beautiful
all right who's next we got
Christian from the US
Christian lay
gut shot
stuff
I love the vibe yeah you've seen the
background
yeah
yeah they got like what is it slippy
versus steel back there it's fun all the
animals getting together for a match
super cool yeah nice lighting yeah yeah
it's one of those like you need some
time to appreciate all the
the attention to the elements so there's
a lot going on yeah yeah 100 the surface
imperfections looks really nice good
materials on your on your Robo
um
some penguins in there that definitely
get some points for me
I love it
yeah good stuff Christian good stuff man
congratulations on top 100.
congratulations let's keep it going uh
next up we got Jason snyman from Canada
come on now what's going on here
spoilers
oh
crazy
I love the animations
yeah
yeah it's really well done
um
it's really clean it's hard like
animation is really tough a lot a lot of
artists struggle with animation uh
myself included
and when you see a smooth one
um they really stand out and and it goes
a long way so this one is just nuts
especially with like a spider because
that's extra tricky
yeah
yeah 100 it just looks so nasty like all
the fur and stuff it's great work
yeah this is awesome lighting is pretty
sweet too
yeah
at first it's a little tricky to
understand that he's taking out a spider
like I think it's pretty obvious now but
like on first viewing yeah it's a little
tough like maybe it's the depth of field
if the focus was on the foreground in
the beginning maybe that could be
helpful I don't know
yeah super sweet congrats Jason
it's just the timing right like
sometimes
because it's a so compressed in terms of
like what you have to do in that amount
of time yes it's more sometimes but
I don't think this is an issue here but
you're right the beginning it takes a
little while for you to get settled and
what's happening yeah
yeah but it's amazing regardless
curious stuff
congrats Jason
uh we have a name that I I cannot read
but maybe we'll go by their Discord Colo
from China
I love the lighting on this one and the
colors
this wreaking havoc in the fridge at
Midnight Man
brutal trying to trying to survive is
that the thing yeah it's like ain't
gonna eat me
sword
I wish it would have went into his mouth
and he's like his eyes go wide or
something right when I get them right
when it hits them
yeah I think this one's really nice
lighting wise
um texture-wise detail I get the
compositions filled out pretty nicely
um lots of little details like pizza on
the left all the the octopus on the
right there's even like a little sausage
guy with a with
like oh my God I just realized I think
this burger killed everyone in the
fridge
maybe yeah it could be a thing
that's dark there's a lot of a lot of
Happening Here 100 yeah
really nice work
super sipping with the to me that that
throws me off just on the storytelling
is I don't know what the boy is doing
because I know he's kind of like funny
yeah but maybe the position of the mouth
is almost like looks like he's about to
eat something maybe I don't know there's
something there that
and obviously with everything else going
on which is awesome like what's on the
fridge that's the only thing that my
eyes keep going back to the boy and I
don't know what's happened
that's a good point yeah it is it is a
little bit uh a little bit confusing you
don't know if he's yawning or if you
don't know if he's going to eat
something
um
that's a very good point position enough
man super cool yes good stuff
good stuff Colo congrats on top 100 all
right next up we got
dosuke from China as well
let's see here
boom
oh damn yeah the lighting colors
yeah I love that like Halo behind his
head and just that top down I'm such a
fan of that top-down lighting like that
just super Punchy mm-hmm
there's some Hellraiser Vibes yeah 100
percent
and the colors on this one I'd play this
game for sure this would be fun
that's uh there's some soul survived
right there yeah 100 lots of souls Vibes
um during this challenge for sure
it sounded like you the effects on the
character I just noticed that I guess
the boss is like
eating their souls or something I don't
know what's going on there yeah he's
like he's like pulling up their essence
or something yeah
it's pretty sweet
school I wish the the activation of the
hero was like bigger so you can kind of
see that contrast yeah because he starts
charging up and then you know
yeah yeah it would be sweet if you maybe
like pulled in some of those rocks those
floating rocks yeah I don't know or
maybe like change the background or
something like like a bigger I'm
here you know yeah let's go baby
this is super cool yeah I just freaking
love the the lighting and the colors on
this one good stuff that's okay congrats
on top 100
uh who is next
um this is these are all so these are
all from China
um and they're in like kanji so I can't
pronounce the names but morinshu maybe
is their Discord so we'll go with that
yeah Dark Souls Vibes 100 yeah
super cool
I think the render quality
this feels like uh you're definitely
like a one of those Final Fantasy movies
or
like 100 cinematic vibes yeah
what is it to you that makes it
cinematic what would you say that
they're doing that makes it feel that
way
um the separation from all the elements
you can see the character
really standing out with that kind of
glowy halo around them yeah then you get
that depth of like okay first element
second element and then there's a couple
layers on the background that gives you
that depth like everything feels very
very cohesive which is super cool yeah
yeah that's a that's a really good tip
having the elements that you want the
the audience to pick out stand out with
like you know all your
your fog here your dust all these layers
and whatnot
um
yeah that just looks awesome super
patient dramatic yeah same this is sick
all right
who's next
James
from China
awesome yeah
[Music]
man she's strong she's throwing that gun
like nothing yeah
he's having trouble with it he's like
yeah
I love like I know this is not
technically accurate with the lighting
there it's like they shine a giant light
into this dude's mouth
um maybe they're trying to say that
those little plasma balls are are
justifying that light
but
it it feels disconnected but at the same
time I kind of like it I like the
lighting so I don't know it's
interesting
yeah
yep I agree with you on that one it'd be
cool to see the little like blue lights
actually affecting right like traveling
through the character to get that sense
of depth yeah and maybe you can even
fake I would probably fake that if we're
actually making this as a city but it's
because this is such a cool scene yeah
agreed
the hand throwing is to me is okay I
guess it goes back to like the time that
you have to tell the story like maybe
it's a little too much or maybe you
didn't need that at the beginning
it'll be cool if maybe he was charging
up or something yeah yeah
because they feel so small compared to
how big the thing is
um
but I love the little little foreground
storytelling here with
the claw the like destroyed claw in the
foreground or Tusk or whatever that is
they're definitely standing on some guts
here too that's that's great super cool
yeah I dig it good stuff James congrats
on top 100 man
all right here we go so we got Scott
Scott from China
awesome Gundam oh yeah this one's
sick
damn
I love the motion of the character in
The foreground
feels it feels so good it's like ah that
it looks so cool
yeah I love this one this is pretty cool
yeah the lighting is really nice the
action's nice
yep storytelling is there using the
slow-mo really well
I mean it sounds kind of right basic but
makes such a huge difference that smoke
in the back to like frame everything
it's it's a nice touch
yeah to like silhouette them that bright
smoke yeah I got that separation and you
can kind of see the some some kind of
rim lights on the the little guy
separate him as well yep I love that
yeah it feels super good
I think the visor to just the whole set
the chains I love the chains reacting to
the hit
ah is that punch too is it I don't know
if this is more capped or not but that
punch when it you see you actually feel
the hit it's not just character just
just turning you know you feel the head
on the head and just mess him up it
makes connection yeah
yeah that's really nice
yeah really really good stuff Scott
anything anything else to mention on
this one or uh should we keep it going
for me yeah let's keep it going I was I
was looking at the chat just for a
second sorry I missed you were coming no
all good all good
let's see
uh so we're still still in China here
we're doing it by country this is
[Music]
this one is a very interesting
interpretation of boss fight
in my rival yeah rival Vibes yeah they
did uh just a really great job uh with
that with that lighting is everything
looks photo real really dig it
yep I guess that was kind of setting
yourself up for that challenge because
it's a tricky shot
yeah
absolutely I love the like dark
foreground and the you know the the
overcast sunlight is hitting the
background only so it kind of separates
them as well it's super nice
all right we watch arrival such a good
movie I know I mean everything that that
director does is just the best he's my
favorite
that's awesome yeah super sick
all right who is next we got
KK
from China
oh this one oh this one
this one's so sick
got some Dune Vibes yeah another movie
crazy
I mean those effects are
pretty sweet yeah like all the sand
simulation the explosions are really
nice a sense of slow motion is just
a wave yeah the Rippling coming towards
camera
just terrifying
all the teeth and stuff it would be cool
to like
see a little bit deeper into the worm's
mouth
um for some contrast and also like would
be absolutely terrifying to just see
like a pit of Darkness
um
I know you're dealing with a bunch of
sand uh in in front of that but
yeah because it to your point it the
I guess the teeth or whatever those
things the little hair on their mouth
like it kind of Blends in with the
amount of sand they have going on so it
just yeah it just looks like sand but
then you once the explosion happens you
actually realize this oh you know it's
all the
the little yeah
dude and it totally just shatters the
mountain on the right
so intense oh yeah I didn't notice that
last time so much going on I'm like
yeah I love super sick
I love that the smoke trails yeah really
nice follow the the action there
good stuff KK
congrats on top 100 really nice
uh this one is from Ben
yang
this one's fine I love this yeah this
one's great Style
yeah Style Style points go a long way
for sure
yeah yeah
such a hard thing to do
yeah because everyone's doing like Photo
real and then like spider-verse comes
out and then everyone's doing
spider-verse and like
It's Tricky It's tricky because the
style is nice because it it really
stands out it feels unique it feels
different
um
but finding that style is is certainly
difficult
yeah it has a lot of interesting tricks
here you know to your point on the
spider verse with the uh overlay on the
highlights
but I don't know if there's an easy way
are you able you can do comp on this
right I mean I guess yes yeah
maybe that was done afterwards
that's awesome yeah it's really fun I
dig the colors the like bam behind the
characters cool too
um I like the interpretation I think
it's a fun interpretation of boss fight
super cool
yeah good stuff been really solid
congrats
all right who's next
this is polycross
I love the motion on this one
nice yeah
definitely a lot going on yeah yeah I
love this idea though it's such a good
idea yeah
that kind of uh slo-mo works really well
but yeah to your point there's there's a
lot happening and I think the movement
of the hero
throws your eyes off while stuff is
happening so it's kind of like you don't
know where to look
that's the main thing
yeah maybe like a little bit of
atmosphere between the hero and the boss
to like separate them a little bit
Edge light definitely helps pop them out
a little bit
you definitely shave his eyebrows there
[Laughter]
yeah
you also have like portals in the back
and there's a lot there's a lot going on
that's crazy I dig it though I love the
style
um they're just like the setting rather
I think it's super cool a building
turning into a boss like that is great
there is a portal there's a freaking
pizza box coming out of the portal yeah
yeah oh my God that's hilarious there's
this like
weird Easter egg running gag on the
server here where people will throw in
pizza boxes into their renders so nice
we found one we found you all right I
wish this is not a small note but I wish
that effect actually came out of its eye
because it also like you're trying to
track the eye but then the effect comes
off of like
his body some other spot yeah that's a
good point man aligning it some of the
elements would probably help maybe like
moving the hero more to the left so
is more centered to the screen that's
like the little things right but there's
there's a lot of cool stuff here no 100
but this is all very helpful yeah like
moving them to the left a little bit
seeing the eye a bit more having the
that blast come out of the eye versus
like a random spot on the building
that's all super solid yeah maybe remove
his backpack too like the things to just
help organize some of the elements yeah
yeah good point good stuff though
polycross super solid from Norway
all right who's next we got
wingy
dude talking about style this one's
crazy
okay definitely some uh
spider-verse Vibes yeah 100 percent
it's funny man people people putting
spider verse stuff into stuff that
doesn't need it like whatsoever this is
not one of them but like it'll be like
you know a normal render and then it
just hits spider verse randomly and it's
like oh man spiderverse has an influence
hard man
but yeah this one is this is one of the
one of the great ones in my opinion like
the the guys in the background just look
so cool to me their poses and the way
they're lit
yeah I like the color change towards the
end is that him
yeah really nice
all the like
I don't know if they're post effects on
top or what but all the scratchiness and
the like flickering background and stuff
um really adds and it looks like they're
flashing lights like but the bottom
right there's like a green emissive
something flashing
and it's bouncing off of that
yeah it helps call attention to that
because I think he's trying to save the
bad character yeah
kind of helps it pop right there's a lot
going on so maybe this same kind of note
which is maybe organizing the elements a
little bit would help
yeah like spotlighting some of the more
important ones
yeah maybe maybe it's the thing right
because when you're working on stuff you
don't realize because you're used to it
and but we're watching for the first
time and kind of like you need to help
you know just be very clear with the
elements
yeah yeah like so how often oh sorry go
ahead go ahead rap oh yeah sorry once we
re-watch for a lot you know many times
you kind of understand everything
but at first I'm pretty much just
looking at the bad guy and shooting this
shooting the lasers
so I was gonna ask like
do you when you're when you're making
your art do you actually build in time
to not be working on it like
specifically to get a fresh perspective
or are you sending it to people that you
trust um to be those fresh eyes for you
so I can speak to like reviewing content
because that's pretty much all I do yeah
I try to look at it once and write down
you know fresh fresh I with fresh eyes
or fresh perspective of okay I'm just
gonna look at this one time and here are
my notes I know I try not to nitpick too
much because that's the artist's job to
make it perfect
but as a director and just more kind of
looking at it and just giving a high
high level perspective of like what's
happening what's the first read like
what are the things that are most
important and then
you know you can kind of get that
perspective from me instead of me like
nitpicking oh you know let's just make
this helmet a little bit more bright you
know brighter or something right so that
works works really well and I try to on
my own stuff like just do that as well
if I look at it for three seconds right
or if I'm scrolling into Instagram like
what is the first thing that I get out
of it uh most people will look at stuff
for a few seconds and move on but that's
kind of the unless you're an artist and
you're analyzing the work and all that
that's that's something I'm always
keeping in mind
what is the
the message you know that's great yeah
first impression basically write down
what our first impression is and uh yeah
yeah and if it's not reading in the
first impression then you know you know
then you go from there basically things
need to be done to it yeah but yeah yeah
I like that
thank you good stuff wingy congrats on
top 100 I love that style super solid we
got Sebastian from Columbia
with a little cartoon render here cat
and mouse Chase
I love this yeah yeah
ocean
storytelling super cool yeah good sense
of slow-mo all the like
little traps popping off
yeah okay it'll be awesome if it was
actually like in his path and he's just
like you're seeing the the traps fly
like to the off the site you know as
he's not running yep agreed
yeah this one they just did a really
good job with the slow-mo um I think a
lot of the artists
um
the slow-mo element
wasn't as interesting it would be just
them standing there and some slow-mo
random slo-mo their hair waving where
that can work but in this case here the
slo-mo element is the is the most
intense action element and that
that that feels very visceral to me um
high energy and just feels cool and fun
they're doing a good job
the the cat has such a nice Arc right
coming coming down yeah it'd be nice if
the if the mouse also had a little bit
of that perspective so you get that
kind of bouncing off the elements
because he is coming straight
yeah the camera yeah so he doesn't read
as nice as the kid but I mean this is
little things right like this is so cool
I like it yeah yeah 100 green
yeah very nice good stuff Sebastian love
it uh who is next we got Andre from
Cypress
oh I love this one this one's super cool
back composition it's nice yeah
so pleasing I know and it's so clean too
the lighting is so nice I love that
overcast like
but with the sun spot you know breaking
through the clouds
I think that that here is just giving up
man he's dropping the I don't know what
he's holding that one he's like holy
yo honestly though here check this
out there let's zoom in because oh it
won't work
basically here can I I have to do it
like this
okay that works
it's a little one
oh it's a ice
that story dude like he's got the babies
coming back he's like I got the sample
guys and this one's like all right
so good
or maybe he stole his his baby now he's
pissed exactly exactly
I just love it like the tentacles the
way the tentacles move they're totally
like slithering up on the thing and
yeah oh I love it
oh yeah you see a guy dropping there
yeah that guy's screwed
yeah this is super cool yeah really good
stuff Andre
the one thing and I I'm here to give
give tips or notes and take it as you
wanted but that's helpful yeah it'll be
cool to see maybe the whatever happened
to the ground because it looks like the
creature is just chilling there yeah I
don't know if maybe you'll see like
splashes and it's like a big lake or
just just something to sell that part as
well
yeah that's a good point like where did
they come from it looks like they just
kind of walked over from the other vat
the other side of the valley versus did
they come out of the water like you
would see the ground be like altered in
a different ways kind of what you're
saying yeah yeah you see that kind of
the bursts or maybe he's already there
and you see just the ground marks or
something mm-hmm
yeah that's a good point where other
ones coming out also maybe like
surfacing could be interesting but yeah
yeah this one's real nice real focused I
dig it
all right Andre solid stuff
next up we got yerca
like this already yeah it's such a good
interpretation it's so good
oh yeah I love this
such a good idea I know
I love the little the mirror too just
kind of showing the oh dude it's perfect
during the hero
is perfect it's
only snaps off what does he snap off
like a
is that a toothpick or something that's
rough
oh that hurts so bad
I need props for that like the effects
too there's a lot of little splinters
just getting yeah
this is nice yeah yeah super great idea
of really good interpretation of of the
prompt
um just really well done solid idea
he should have done the the little dead
the dead uh dead ones a little rotten
yeah I think that would be funny yeah
some decay
or make the
make the hero like the crown you know
like the gold gold tooth or something oh
yeah yeah I don't know that's fun but
yeah this is super sick I love it it's
like that's the thing but it's such a
good idea uh different from everything
we've seen there's a lot of things you
could play that's super nice yeah
yeah stands out for sure
um next up we got Matthias
TS from El Salvador
I love that model
I love the explosion too yeah they did a
good job with the emissive
the voxels
and RoboCop action on the
the Super Nintendo oh yeah
what is the name of that
it was like Ed 409 or red two or
something what was it
I forget yeah at 209 yeah
nice yeah I just love I love that like
turning a console into a robot because
I'm I'm a huge gamer obviously so
this one is
this one's cool for me
solid stuff
immediate KO too brutal
good stuff Matthias congrats I love the
mix of uh medium steel if you know
realistic background with the pixel art
yeah yeah
100 percent
a lot of games are kind of trying to do
that which is It's Tricky
what makes it what makes it tricky what
what's hard about that
um I mean I think it's just a balance of
all the elements like making it
making you feel believable the lighting
I haven't actually tried myself but it
seems like a not an easy thing to do
yeah because like what is it uh
having your design be uniform throughout
what people are seeing right uh like the
continuity of design and when you're
splitting it to two different things
I guess yeah it would be the balance of
those two of those two different styles
that would
constantly have to be in check
yeah yeah
this one's sick dig it yeah I love it
all right Fraser
from Ethiopia is next
nice yeah
yeah this one's very clear what's going
on here really cool story
yeah the only thing that that I'm trying
to understand or is throwing me off is
the filter that's on top
agreed not like blending stuff in yeah
it's like some sort of like uh
AI filter pass on top or something
yeah yeah
because I I mean in terms of
Storytelling and the elements like this
this is one of those there is very clear
I love that yes
trying to tell that story I wish that
was more happening with the
bad guy's face
is that such like a key element of the
thing yeah
it works it works for that simplicity
yeah 100 percent
yeah but they have the consistent style
going throughout I love the the like the
fogginess in the background is cool too
um
almost feels like 2D and 3D combined
right in a weird way yeah very painterly
so that's cool
yeah good stuff Fraser who's next we got
Eloy from France
where you got Eloy
here we go
I love this the composition the lighting
yeah super cool
yeah real sharp Lighting on the hero
there has them stand out real nice
and that robot has a bad swing
that's it
it worked dude you want to know you know
what you want to know sad the sad truth
what I think that's my that's my swing
I'm okay
did you vocab this this is you swinging
yeah yeah
that's funny oh man I don't know I mean
hey maybe maybe the artist you know did
some tweaking to it I don't know but uh
if the robot is like screaming and then
you see the thing coming in the mouth
because there's a moment there where you
almost like cut to an explosion
yeah it makes no sense
yeah it's like
I think that's a thing where
kind of back what I was talking to about
the the slo-mo element happening at the
very end
and it would have been cool to have a
little bit of a slow-mo explosion in the
robot's mouth as it's yelling yeah yeah
but the render quality is nice I really
like the lighting
um depth of field super cool
that is beautiful yeah
it looks like one of those the love
death and robots uh shorts you know yeah
I can see it I can see that totally good
stuff Eloy
way to go man way to go
we got
low Laurent
from France
[Music]
no selfie yeah
yeah I love that slow-mo there this is
like perfect perfect example of having
using your slow-mo at the right time
yeah yeah
it is really hard to
see the car coming maybe because it's
like turning at the beginning it feels
just like on frame before you he hits it
yeah makes it a clear you know a clear
read of like what's going on because at
first when I first saw I was like oh
this car just popped out of nowhere
yeah okay maybe if it was like drifting
up from the right side or something yeah
yeah I was I was in camera I was in
frame
yeah that guy the little selfie robot
was like more more to the left something
to help with the elements yeah he's
blocking it just a touch
animation is super clean yeah I dig it
looks like they're doing like some nice
nice lines with the clouds up top like
they feel deliberate you know coming
streaking across the sky and hooking to
the right over there it feels pretty
cool yeah yeah
good stuff Laurent
congrats on top 100 man good stuff
all right we got we got Jonah
from Germany
goodness
lots of Ashes yeah like the skin burning
off and turning all skeleton-like oh
yeah that's crazy
also like the skin hanging afterwards
nice detail yeah 100 100 percent
yeah insane render quality
yeah
really technical this is crazy yeah huge
yeah yeah
with like the feet interacting with the
mud
as well on her is crazy
yep
they're seeing this pretty tough to do
yeah
that's pretty darn clean is it you're
right it's really good technical
showcase
on this one
yeah yeah I feel like the I don't know
if maybe lighting or maybe just framing
would help separate things a little bit
better
because it's a lot maybe also right like
thematically like all kind of feels the
same same color which is maybe a choice
for what what it is it's just really a
little bit hard to
pick all the the cool stuff that's
happening
just one View
yeah also like uh the hero's a little
large
compared to like the template
but you know it was okay to scale up or
scale down
uh you know as needed as long as it
wasn't too much
um I think this one just barely
barely does it there
um
yeah nice particles in there good film
grain like yeah this one's insane
ridiculous good stuff Jonah you should
be very proud
we've got yeah it's got everything this
guy everything
damn
there's a lot going on yeah super nice
yeah 100 percent
all right next up we got Michael
from Germany
I freaking love this one the the girl's
face
it's like doesn't feel janky to me oh
yeah yeah
it was scary I know
yeah babe
um
yeah I appreciate how they like
they use the slow-mo here really nicely
and the story continued all the way to
the end with the parents coming in and
the monster disappearing
yep
maybe they could have came in like a
half second earlier
so it's not like a what was that kind of
a thing
right I think faking out maybe some God
race also would help tell that story
um from the window or from the door from
the door because it it's such a drastic
change when that happens yeah
yeah
it kind of comes off a little
Yari
oh man I just love that though like
the girl's face it's so well done I love
it
really nice Michael congrats on top 100
still holding it down for Germany we got
Felix
let's go yeah
the Lightning's super cool wait bounces
off those buildings lights up the entire
environment
yep the rain
someone's driving
on a day like this on the bottom right I
don't know what they're doing
but but they're coming back from the
store or something
it's probably like a love interest or
someone that wants to to protect the
hero but it's gonna end up being a
distraction
oh man
funny there's a helicopter coming by too
yeah yeah lighting is super cool I love
the the Thunder when it hits and you see
like flashes flashes the hero like
that's a nice touch
yeah in the rain seeing the rain and uh
through
the volumetrics of the actual lights
there of the light cone I think that's
really nice too
dang they got like water particles
falling off the top of the robot too
super nice
yeah this one's sick
don't forget a little footstep nice
touch
yeah the water splashes
my only thing is like is this Star Wars
or is this like how is this like a
mashup of Star Wars and like Mech
Warrior or something I'm not sure
enough said congrats Felix love it what
was that new uh Zack Snyder movie it's
about come out and he's like
we just kind of make Star Wars like a an
amazing Star Wars I forgot what exactly
what he said but he's he's
Reinventing the lightsaber basically
wait is that you're saying there's a
movie that he's that he's coming out
with that's not out yet
it's not out yet it's like it's a
Netflix movie oh interesting
Rebel Moon that's the one and it's not
Star Wars but it but it's no no it's not
it's not ours but they have like
lightsabers so I think he gave you an
interview saying that he's just gonna
make Star Wars look amazing or whatever
his thing is heck yeah such as like
Snyder thing to do I'm down for it let's
see what he does
uh let's see Felix that's what's up man
congratulations on top 100 we got Robin
next this is from Germany as well
God damn
yo this is clean I like this yeah me too
the colors everything stands out the
lighting the edge light there
yeah
cool design on the character I love the
Rocks like the simulation here with the
smoke and the rocks and then they bounce
off the wall and shoot back that's super
cool
nice little like a natural vignette of
the scene too with the
with the roots and stuff
yeah such a good friend with the pillars
on the on the side
gives that depth when the camera pans
around in the slow motion too and I know
you bring that up on some of the other
ones like this feels
the right timing to do
just spinning around yeah it's a super
sick flip
yeah just the colors I love that like
cyan
with the orange down below
super nice contrast
it helps to frame the
the bad guy
yeah 100 100 really really nice work
Robin from Germany congratulations on
top 100 baby
who's next we got
Roman
[Music]
wait wait for it
Roman
hitting us with the Spider-Man is one of
maybe two
Spider-Mans who made it in so many
people did Spider-Man stuff
gotta do it that slow motion yeah 100
really nice
little Octavius fight
[Music]
yeah this is clean I like it yeah maybe
the poses could be a little better
yeah a little bit more stretched out or
something
yeah
for probably both characters right
because like even Octavius like maybe
you could
I see what he's doing but it feels a
little within silhouette not not as
interesting and Spidey yeah I think
the movement is cool it's just you lose
his body on the slow mo yeah
yeah maybe like pulling the left leg to
the ground a little bit
like stretching that leg out a little
bit closer to the ground when it comes
back around
little tweaks but this one feels really
nice overall it's like really nice
slow-mo you got the papers flying in the
foreground the particulate and
everything super cool
those papers really threw me off first
time I was watching really what the heck
was that I don't know if there was like
too much within frame or
maybe maybe you're out of focus and had
some more movement they're kind of just
like going by
yeah Fair maybe you'd have him at the
top of the shot out of focus a little
bit to set them up come in at the end
they might be like a little uh
a little confusing that's that's a good
point very fair
heck yeah good stuff Roman
that's what's up
we got bows
from India
thank you
all right right at a uh elbow yeah
this was a fun fight
insane Lighting on this
yeah this is awesome
I've never seen uh
yeah go ahead oh just a quick one on the
maybe some rim lights on the the hero
there will help
with the elements
to like pop them out right separate them
yeah because everything has that same
same hue yeah
yeah bear
very fair you're gonna say something I'm
sorry Quinn oh no all good yeah so like
uh we saw one of these guys on the
Discord or a previous render of this on
the Discord server and they were like
uh they had all those swords and Spears
there was more of them and they were
blocking the hero and the boss and they
they cleaned that up and they actually
removed some which was a good move on
their part
um
uh one note I would have here is the
background
the the actual brightest point of the
sky should probably be clipped to white
as opposed to
I think it's like dimmed down or
something but that should definitely be
like full White
that's just me
and also the position right it's a it's
a but now that you brought it up the
position of the sun doesn't really match
the lighting hmm I see yeah I should be
on the far left once you've noticed that
it throws you off there's something with
the castle that
feels a little a little off but I think
it's just because it's
it's being backlit from the from the sky
but not really yeah okay
very fair but yeah I love it I love the
like red the red Vibe here super cool
scene you got good stuff bows
who's next all right we got uh yasu
tacos from Japan
oh he broke his blade I see it yeah
well forehead slash two
would have been sick if you took an eye
out you know like
yeah yeah
or the continuation of the move where
the heroes just as that slash is super
clean but I don't get the sense that he
did it because I don't see the sword
yeah Fair
so maybe just just stick that pose and
just keep it
we go be clean good point yeah it looks
like they have a little sword slash
uh animation or a little line here too
let's see
right there oh yeah yeah
maybe like continuing that or something
yeah
it'd be nice to see you like right when
that happens you see the the blood just
to get the connection yeah
I almost thought his sword cut his head
because it's spinning on that direction
ah interesting yeah
yeah something there yeah that's fair
that's fair I love the the Sim though
the cloth stem I love the use of slow-mo
I think the color
um
yeah this one's a super fun one
yeah the environment is super clean yeah
the lights on the left yeah that's a
good
position super solid
good stuff yasutaka congratulations top
100 who's next we got Stefan
from Canada
nice little gut simulation I don't know
if that's a simulation but
cool I love the beginning when you just
like throwing up three guys yep like
it's nothing
yeah the hero's like oh crap
crap yeah super cool storytelling there
yeah
it's a nice subsurface scattering
and like the mouth and the eyes the face
is cool fingertips
yeah yeah
super clean like looking at the the
previous one to this like this could be
a little punch here on the lighting I
think it will help a lot
I can see that
yeah for sure it's a little flat
yep
yes I'm sick 100 percent
yeah like little like
Kilt a little cloth thing that they got
that the giant has is cool just love
that slow-mo hit really good
stuff Stefan shout outs to you man uh we
have
Nathaniel from the Philippines
let's get over to it
ah this one's cool
nice yes
some of the ones that it's more of my my
style I feel like there's such a clean
composition
what makes it your style when you say
like the the the other worldly like
fantasy element to it or is it more so
like the lighting and the composition
yeah I think it's it's like the
Simplicity but if you break it down
there's a lot happening that you can
kind of you can make your your own
stories because it's a nice
is a nice sense of mystery and and
you're very clear what's happening yeah
yeah not that the other ones weren't
myself but like this to me like speaks
to that's what's up um that kind of
storytelling element
yeah I dig it
I just the lighting is so nice on this
one it's very focused it's very centered
um very very clean
vignette around the edge is like really
nice natural natural vignette
really cool idea for the boss very
unique
yeah I feel like the if the metal maybe
if the metal was rougher yeah um it
would help just kind of make things sit
in better because you're getting a lot
of the the reflection
on the scene that maybe is working
against you hmm
giving all those like highlights on the
top left you know yeah I'm like
I quite don't know what that's coming
from Fair
yeah it almost looks like a sword blade
it's so sharp
yeah yeah
super cool composition this is nice
uh we got a super chat from Joshua
thanks man I appreciate it you're tuning
in from South Africa it's a big fan
awesome awesome
heck yeah
um Nathaniel that's what's up man
congratulations on top 100 we love it
but we moving on we go into Alexander
from Russia
oh that's cool yeah I love those yeah
some uh Game of Thrones vibes
just disgusting if you ask me like I
don't want anything to do with this oh
so well done though my goodness
definitely reminds me of just grinding
in Dark Souls up in the tombs man just
breathing in dust
Jesus I love this yeah this is sick
yeah
the uh
the flame on the sword towards the end
that's the only thing I wish the focus
would be more on the creature because
that's like the review and you want that
holy moment expectation yeah but
there's so much going on on the sword
that kind of throws you off
yeah it extends and I think they're
trying to like
justify the fact that he'd be able to
reach that boss from where he's standing
but it may not be necessary
um
I think it could still work with a short
blade you know because it's an elemental
kind of attack but yeah you're right I
think having the focus on the spider
yeah such a good animation too it's kind
of like it reacts to it yeah and it's so
clean look at that yeah it curls up be
nice to see it like expand and comes at
you
I love the fire on the cloth too when he
activates
oh snap I didn't catch that that's cool
that's so sick
yeah I really like this yeah I think
this one definitely works for like um
uh a kind of a uniform lighting uniform
color rather
because I don't know like maybe you
could throw a Moonlight in somewhere but
I think it totally works when you're up
in the tombs that warm light you know it
works
yeah yeah especially for that contrast
on the
storytelling yeah this will be
amazing if you had a little bit more of
that impact
he's already is super sick I
love it yeah
what's up Alexander uh we got
next
little goosebusters
bro
yeah lots going on in this one like that
they're Elemental blasts are really well
done actually
yeah
I don't know how they're doing that
really cool
it could be an After Effects thing
honestly
maybe yeah
I feel like uh
doable yeah looks good though yeah the
lighting's nice render quality is good
um
yeah he goes back into that sign real
real nice I like that
car I don't know if you need the car to
be honest but it's a cool
asset I don't know if it works for the
opposition
yeah I like maybe they're trying to
justify like that that's like the hero
the singular one or something like
but not that's fair that's fair
oh this one's sick I love it
the thing that I want to point out that
please maybe he's a small small note but
the the hdr on the back it looks like
it's uh projected building image motor
quality
in contracts with everything else that's
on the scene
throws me off a little yeah Fair we can
like blur it out or something
yeah yeah
smell no this is freaking sick yeah 100
percent
100 percent
yeah all the particles like paper it's
really nice too
the sign
um
super super solid next up we got Anton
oh this is very different
which is good different is good wow yeah
yeah like activating the special move
you know they did the red green color
combo without really making it look like
Christmas which is uh that's a good
thing
I'm trying to understand the character
because
I see the shield and I see the spear and
then
a wand
three three arms
uh the head like yeah where is the head
it's like around the Halo I guess maybe
this guy
yeah yeah that's the head I think so
yeah maybe it's just me yeah again it's
one of those where you like yeah where
you see something completely different
yeah yeah
that's funny
yeah I love the style on this one it's
super nice um
got the nice atmosphere going I I the
the only thing is I wish they did they
stuck the texture to the dragon as
opposed to having it like
um
oh yeah yeah just be in 3D space like
that but
yeah why is that
oh that's more of like a filter on top
to add detail it's like a I think it's a
texture or something with an animated
texture but it's not sticking
for some reason but
but anyway
it's pretty sweet
yeah
texture mapping but uh no that's good
stuff
Anton congratulations to you for top 100
moving on to Merrick
oh this one's cool like this Slovakia
yeah the lighting on this it's very
unique very very unique
um
yeah very simple
this has to me like a like an 80s Vibe
where it's like the Simplicity is there
but there's also a lot of high frequency
uh detail it's almost like uh
you know like real sets and real uh
puppets which is yeah
I could see that yeah because the render
quality is really nice everything looks
pretty darn photo real
yeah
one of those that maybe the animation is
not helping
because he's doing a lot in
getting this the scissors with the tail
it's almost like
unnecessary at the beginning I don't
know if he was just like or you know
kind of getting ready to chop some
some hair yeah maybe like a scissor spin
and then yeah yeah and a cool pose and
just maybe holding the scissor it's
almost like okay badass yeah let's do it
oh it's just the lighting on this one is
so cool
um yeah it's so unique to me great work
with the fur and the hair good stuff
Marek really love it
we got you know if you haven't I don't
know how old these people are but you
know make sure you watch Dark Crystal
you know Labyrinth all the good hint you
know the classics yeah yeah 100 you know
Let's see we got Joseph next up
Slovakia
super cool
yeah it kind of reminds me of uh I think
that one of the Killzone games had
a boss like this I think
I'm such a sucker for like massive
industrial stuff
um especially if it's real you know like
oil rigs and whatnot like that's just
crazy to me that humans can build that
kind of stuff so this has that Vibe for
me
yeah
it's simple I like it yeah
yeah 100 got the birds flying off nice
touch good stuff with the trees on the
Stomp
should probably delay that uh oh I just
saw some eyes on the roof there nice
touch I don't know if that was part on
purpose but
[Laughter]
probably delay the the cloth
uh moving because I feel like this step
maybe we'll take you like a second to
get to the hero oh you're 100 yeah a
Shockwave of some sort would be would be
a nice touch
it almost get you like the one two of
like the motion
right now everything's happening at the
same time
yeah that's a good point
I love it though yeah good stuffing
super solid good stuff Joseph
all right from South Africa we got
Calvin
nice yeah
this one's super simple too
just like yep a couple lights super dark
yep yep we're missing something on the
end there like that impact
yeah
it's a little weak
maybe seeing like a
get a gold faster or the creatures
expand or just something to help tell
that story yeah the I the iris maybe
expands and opens up when he slams or
something yeah I change color or
something
that's fun I love that just the lighting
that bone
you got bone vortex
scary stuff
um from Switzerland we got Frederick
oh this one's so much fun
that's awesome yeah
almost like a colored pencil or crayon
Style
yep
got that uh almost like children's book
kind of vibe
yeah story is pretty clear too
yeah in great use of slow-mo as well
like busting through the Rocks smashing
out like that
slow-mo dive
really nice and the way it like actually
spawns on too is cool so
it starts here and I don't know if these
are hand painted or hand colored or what
but
they almost look like that
it starts to get more detail
and then this might this might be the
first
frame here or something I don't know
it's hard to tell
and then I think it does it at the end
as well
foreign
's out oh
yeah this one's sick I love it
really really nice stuff Reggie good uh
good motion there
nice black
uh next up we got urine
you red from Taiwan
[Music]
real nice style going for that Ghibli
Style
yeah everything looks painted yeah
prepping for battle
yeah cool clouds too
a nice uniform style throughout
did you fire the rocket yeah
oh just barely yeah
the tricky part is like trying to fit in
as much as you can in those five seconds
and still having to use the slow-mo as
well is tough
yeah I don't know if you needed that
beginning
um
throwing the piece out
maybe it was just turning to like shoot
yeah yeah I could see that this is a
little too much but yeah I love the
style designs are 1.2 really nice color
uh
the red green is super nice painterly
effect you just nailed it good stuff
you're in
sometimes like this is something uh for
myself that I'm always thinking about
like as an artist when you're doing this
stuff and especially if you're modeling
or painting things that you want to show
as much as like I want to show the
character's face like you know I want to
kind of show off the the models but
most times like if you don't do it it's
better as a product when you're just
kind of focusing on like if he was just
starting facing the other way it'll
still work you know still be a strong
shot
I don't know if that's what you were
trying to do there
but just something to keep in mind
that's fair yeah that's fair you put all
your work into it you know it's like
when you uh you know write a script or
even edit uh you know edit a film you
want to leave all the stuff all the hard
work on screen but like sometimes it's
best to just cut and uh I guess it's
true in this case as well so that's fair
yeah that's why you don't let an artist
direct the shot or just be the solo
thing person working on it because you
need that other perspective where
someone that doesn't care about the
models or doesn't care about the art
it's just more what's important what do
we want to see
uh so it's always good to you know kind
of check if you're serving you know
serving the shot rather than making a
make an RP store
something like that
so when you get to the end of a project
say for a personal project for yourself
right when you're doing both roles
you're playing the artist and the art
director
um that's another case where you where
you have to kind of step back
uh take a break and then look at it from
the art director's perspective right
yeah or think about it if you were on a
different role or have like a gut check
with someone else to be like
have a you know an honest opinion about
things
yeah very important super super
important
um but good stuff you're in congrats on
top 100
next up we got Sergey from Thailand
I just love the story on this one man so
cool
yeah this is awesome
and then it disappears like that
that smile is so creepy and it's like
the way it it's expression at the end is
really nice too
yeah I love this it's super cool
freaking creepy like Dark Fantasy
storybook kind of Vibes you can have
some Tim Burton style 100 percent
yeah the makeup on the face too is
really cool texture there is nice
if you could if you could do one thing
on this one rap what would it be
one time
probably lighting right if you boost up
that backlight you got some rim on the
character
on the other side like uh the big guy on
the Clown
yeah yeah cause that blue light's super
super nice in the back
I feel like uh if that was playing chair
you would get a nice
nice composition
solid yeah I kind of lose the hat in the
on the back left a bit
yeah yeah
I love the curtains too like just really
framing the shot yup that natural
vignette is great
really nice
super solid Sergey congrats on top 100
who do we got who's up next we got uh
Muhammad from Turkey
all right put this insane shot there you
go you gotta have a
big shark yeah right I love this oh it's
so good
oof
oh man he Fires at him and chips his
tooth at the end there
oh yeah yeah
this one is so insane I just wish there
was more lightning because like dude
look how
good this looks right here
oh that's so crazy I just want more of
that and then uh you know you hit him
here with like the
this blast just looks so nice
yeah it's such a nice touch towards the
end there because you get that little
flash yeah
yeah 100 percent
I would love to see that tail actually
on the left side when he jumps up
and I pick that
number lose you lose his body a little
bit there this is super cool
yeah that's a good point
oh this one's great
really good stuff great Sim
great idea good stuff Muhammad
up next from Ukraine we got Andrew
where you at Andrew
Little D and D action here love those
colors
yeah this is beautiful
yeah the purple orange is sick
the lighting on this one is just really
nice
and crispy
super Punchy dig it
yeah yeah the assets are awesome too
this works really well
love the tight
nice kind of Animation yeah this is
super clean hitting the other character
yeah
beautiful yeah real nice render quality
really dig it
uh Andrew this is super solid
congrats on top 100 man the guy's in the
back too super cool I was like
that's a thing right like you
it's really well done like you don't
they're there they're doing things but
you don't
putting too much focus on that it's just
adding to the whole
the whole scene yeah fair fair and that
would just that would be lighting right
you know it's just because they're kind
of they're they're
they're darker off to the sides I guess
amazing yeah good stuff good stuff
Andrew congrats we got Enrique from the
US up next
boom
let's go Gotta gotta love a good surface
here
yeah I just love that that's slo-mo use
of slow-mo is perfect
okay yeah
that's a boss battle right there 100
little ground destruction looking nice
super cool love it yeah nice part of it
everything's yeah everything's done
right here super nice yeah heck yeah
congrats Enrique top 100 baby Logan is
next
from the US
as well
solid lighting yeah yeah there's a lot
going on huh
yeah ropes pulling
got the nice like
warbles in the Rope that's cool
yeah I take the blue
I like that girl's just bored in the
house
it's just waiting I am not fighting
just cradling a chicken
yeah the lighting on this one's cool
it pops nicely
yeah the style super yeah yeah agreed
good stuff Logan congrats dude
all right we got hydraulic bean bag
gross this is a crazy design yeah I know
huh
duper weird looking
yeah yeah I like it yeah same got the
eggs hatching in the foreground
is this
I think this dude was just hatched the
hero was just hatched it looks like all
the goo coming off of them oh yeah
there's another one hatching uh-huh
front
this girl I love that wet nasty specular
material
this is wild yeah super out there I love
it otherworldly for sure yeah yeah
there's something in the back too I
don't know what it is it's some hills
yeah what is that kelp or something
I don't know
did you get a chance to play uh tears of
the Kingdom the new Zelda game by chance
uh a little bit I watched a ton but yeah
I haven't played that much myself it
kind of reminds me of like the depths in
that game the underground KV areas
super nice good stuff Mr hydraulic bean
bag congratulations on top 100
uh we got
Logan
up next Bam from the US here we go
back to see some Legolas
can you do this right
the idea is really good
yeah I mean if I saw Legolas just
getting ready in the front there is the
hero I'll be like okay
[Laughter]
it's cool yeah super sick animation is
pretty clean yeah nice little slide
there a little smack a Rooney
is there okay so does this feel lighting
wise does this feel a little like dim or
flat to you
yeah for sure I think so yeah it's just
you don't know where the sun is coming
from
what would you do to tweak that
uh probably tweet change the sky and
then maybe pick a different some sand
angle yeah okay like I don't I see the
the elephant
sorry this is not an elephant but you
know what I'm saying in the back being
like front lit which is a little weird
because all the guys are backlit so
there's some inconsistencies with uh
um okay okay fair fair
yeah
I dig it though good stuff real nice
motion nice scene
solid stuff Logan congrats on top
100. we are almost halfway through
almost halfway through
let's what the the
kill
is that his name the yeah yeah the Beast
I wanna I don't want to be disrespectful
by Lord of the Rings
oh that's good
who's next we got Christian from Germany
I love this one
oh
that slow-mo is just great those colors
yeah yeah that's clean
boom
I think he added the
the lavender or whatever
plant slash flower that is
like right at the end for that purple
contrast
purple guys contrast I think it works
really well
yeah a nice little slice there I love
the way the heroes like
gliding along like that motion carries
through real nicely
mm-hmm
yeah such a good idea I like it truly
like this is a good example of like your
sword doesn't need to actually be that
long like it it totally works you know
right
it's all about that that trail effect
yeah and like the whole environment is
reacting to that slice like the Rocks
the petals even the clouds
all get moved along from the slice there
it just feels so impactful
yeah really good stuff Christian
super solid
uh
uh who else who do we got we got
Sun
hang apologies if I'm butchering that
from South Korea
there we go yeah
I love this one super cool
yeah the hero stands out nicely
with the lighting the side lights
yep that blue pop like really calls your
eyes to it
yeah 100 percent
the level is really well lit
like the underlining in the background
the side lighting
on both the hero and the boss it's
really good the like silhouetted
Scaffolding in the foreground is sick
yeah you get the sense of danger there
with the effects and the shooting of the
bullets is pretty nice be nice to see
some some like Sparks on the on the boss
as it's shooting
that's the only thing yep yeah hitting
the hitting his chest or something
mm-hmm
yeah 100 percent
oh real nice real good stuff
good stuff son
heck yeah we'll do a couple more
here we're about halfway through
um and then Rapha would take like uh
like three minute break or something and
we'll come back in yep up to you man I'm
good I'm chilling cool cool this is fun
yeah let's do a couple more and we'll
take a three minute break here
um Alexis is next from Malaysia
um yeah
goddamn
right like the the Breakaway of the
mountains on the left and right there
with the flags there's a lot going on
here yeah yeah love the lighting for
sure
super cool
like the underglow on the boss
yeah it's like they're coming out of
some portal on the ground or something
yeah this is sick I love the hero
charging up
yeah it's well done she's about to hit
him too there's a lot of yeah a lot of
good stuff here
the attention to detail is crazy like
all the like The Village on the whole
right yeah you're taking out a village
and you're also like this is a very
ambitious shot
um
the particle effects are nice the way
the boss spawns into the flowy emissive
Veil is super cool yeah yeah
yeah how he comes up too is nice a lot
of good movement
yeah let's see
is a little wobbly
animation too
super cool it looks like the there's
like wireframe almost I think it's being
built up
yeah that's fine yeah there is a
wobbliness to it it's like kind of fat
at the ends there and then shrinks down
to size
that's oh that's super cool
really really good stuff good colors too
yeah for sure it's super clean good
stuff Alexis congrats on top 100
uh Matt from New Zealand is next
let's take a look at this Cactus battle
oh man
getting destroyed I know these dudes
were just he's getting wrecked
I get a lot of a lot of explosion yeah
freaking mayhem out here
like right now this is going on in
someone's life
somewhere in the world
yeah and I got that purple green
contrast nice yeah beautiful
Lots going on with the particles and
whatnot the rat the ragus is like a
rabbit
team of rabbits Western rabbits or
something
it's a boss battle I've ever seen one
yeah yeah
that the the dead body in the front it's
a nice storytelling element there but
yeah maybe it doesn't help much with the
with the action yeah because like the
hero is a bit missing right
yeah yeah
especially because there's
a lot at the beginning so you kind of
like
pick some pick a place to look
I love it though this is super cool yeah
oh go ahead yeah yeah
look at this rabbit on the right
this back right
here this rabbit is like riding the wave
that's great yeah yeah some grapple
going on yeah
awesome
really good stuff
solid solid work Matt congrats on top
100 all right we'll do one more it will
take three minute break we'll come back
to it
oh man this one this one's fun
oh what
yeah let's go yeah
I was not expecting that
I know great great A B like storytelling
here
yeah
such a great idea
yeah man really really well done
I love it yeah yeah that kind of
friend's like so convincing too
it's good
the Chuck like the throw
yeah you see the cloth like everything
yeah the way his foot comes up
everything
yeah lighting is good
ah yeah really well done it's got a nice
grade to it as well
it's just kind of firing on all
cylinders here really good
yeah
ought to get now
everyone scary I know dude not good
don't mess with the boss
next up we got Sam from the US
crushing it with this nice vibrant
colorful piece of art here
all right
that's beautiful yeah pretty cool
yeah I really love this one the super
painterly this one was based off of uh
one of their one of the artists favorite
painters his name's murakami something
or something murakami it's not the the
author it's the painter
um
and uh
yeah all their stuff's like super
vibrant like this I think it just really
worked out for them here for this piece
of art
yeah
what is happening he's painting his his
portrait yeah yeah this is cool
isn't that that's the flower guys right
yeah
flower guy what you mean
yeah yeah Takashi murakami he does flour
oh okay yeah yeah
got you yeah I'm not I'm not familiar I
just when I Google Haruki murakami it's
like did you mean this other murakami
that's all I know yeah
it really hardly translate to 3D so it
props to you man this is yeah
yeah I dig it 100 really really nice
congrats top 100 for you Sam
awesome awesome we got a Nicholas up
next from Ecuador
let's see what's going on
I love the designs yeah super creepy and
like otherworldly fantasy Vibes the head
of the boss is cool it's like a universe
and a marble
yeah yeah he has a goddamn what his name
's name oh man I'm not gonna remember
his name but yes this is an artist that
also does a lot of the kind of Astral
God like designs yeah
it's cool
super sick
yeah I love the color the like green
purple contrast is super nice
yeah yeah
little sword silhouetted in the
foreground too is cool
Peter oh man what's his last name
but if it comes to me or you know yeah
100 100 percent
there's a lot of cool stuff here super
nice peter morbach it looks like uh yeah
yeah yeah Peter yeah
thanks chat yeah the chat knows what's
up
yeah mysterious I was thinking Mysterio
that's great oh yeah definitely has the
mystery Vibes yeah
uh next up we got some Yin from Spain
ah I love it
that's awesome yeah
very filmic
yeah yeah something with the kind of
Simplicity of the shot very striking
yeah I dig it nice colors
the only thing maybe the textures
like the surface imperfections
on like the middle X of the face of that
boss
maybe use it like bevel some Edge there
or something but
that's nitpicky super nitpicky
I would love if if uh actually maybe the
lighting was darker and you see the
emissive turning on before the
the main light pops on like I'll just
invert the elements so you can kind of
get that
uh you don't know what it is and you see
that it turns on
because there's yeah 100 percent
it's more of a taste thing like this it
works it works like this yeah like more
of a reveal
everything yeah
that's sick good stuff some
congrats on top 100
uh next up we have
hex 3D
oh my God I love this one
from the US
ah so good
yeah this is very unique compared to the
other ones right
yeah of that effect
beautiful
yeah
it's
it's 3D it's all 3D but it looks 2D and
just that motion is so clean
I'd play this game in a heartbeat for
sure yeah yeah Power pose in the end yep
awesome
yes
good stuff hex I love this one man
next up we got
uh Tran Wen from Vietnam
love that stylized
yeah yeah some Paper Mario
an animation is super clean yeah agreed
very well done
yeah good colors
very simple too like really good job on
kind of taking simplified characters
yeah putting them together like this in
a nice way is good stuff
heck yeah yeah yeah of the fire too when
coming off from all the yeah the mouths
yeah nice touch yeah super solid good
stuff Tran went congrats on top 100
moving on to South Korea we got
Julie
young Julie from South Korea doing a
little Pokemon scene
let's go yeah
yeah the lighting on this one's super
cool the way it shines through that
Crystal there is just really nice yeah
yeah
it's a beautiful shot yeah
foreign
oh yeah go ahead
I don't know the only thing is like
maybe if the crystals were shatter a
little faster so you can see the that
would maybe spend a little more time
with the final
final shot will help yeah yeah
like maybe his head pokes through first
or something
yeah yeah
I'm always a fan of uh of when
the the characters in The foreground are
so far away that the depth of field like
they're blurry in the foreground and
it's focused on something large in the
background it makes it just feel so huge
and they're totally doing that here I
love it
yep
heck yeah
real nice render quality too
yeah yeah
agreed agreed good stuff
uh who is next we got from Argentina
feydae
absolutely
I love this yeah
nicely done yeah
yeah it's like
it's stylized but it's also
like kind of photo real too yeah yeah
I remember him saying he was going for
the the like a recent Godzilla poster
it looked like this and he was trying to
get that Vibe into like this kind of
video form
I think he did a good job
yeah this is awesome
when the creature
comes out and you see that light on his
mouth is such a good shot like right
there but then you lose that when the
beam is
is activated
um
almost like if the light changes it'll
be nice to kind of keep that because
like that's such a cool
you know kind of beams across the teeth
yeah yeah because like like here yeah
and then maybe taking this leaving that
and then adding that or something
that would be cool okay I love I love
the composition the buildings
a tail in the back this is sweet yeah
yeah really really well done good stuff
today
shout outs
we got Ben Hansen
from Australia
yeah
really cool idea for the boss
a little transformation sequence there
too
super solid a little slide in
there's a lot going on I'm just watching
trying to
understand the whole storytelling yeah
so it's like you have little tubas or
horns in the crowd
right this dude's a bell
broke off of something it looks like
fell off of something
there's
like judges on the each of the sides
those
people are just
that's funny yeah there's like on the
far ends right yeah there's like yeah
yeah
it's awesome
good stuff good stuff Ben
congrats on that top 100 next up we got
William from Australia
oh God dang
super cool beautiful lighting yeah I
love the lighting composition is cool
very well done pretty pretty simple
it works yeah maybe getting like a fire
or just something to contrast uh give a
little bounce
like a cave look but
make it more striking
yeah that's not a bad idea
maybe like oh man
if they had a if the character was at a
fireplace and when it yelled it like put
it out or something yeah yeah yeah
it was awesome bad hand the left hand is
also super clean to helping the frame
um frame left or frame rate
uh the right right on the screen like
his left hand his left yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's getting that kind of nice
curve framing the the shot just 100
percent
yeah good point really nice
super cool yeah good stuff William
congratulations on top 100 love this one
we got uh another Ben
from Australia oh shoot let's go oh
classic here
we had to check this one we were like
did he rip this from the movie uh
so we had we had to do some digging here
to make sure that wasn't the case
I mean That's a classic shot for sure
right different angle I guess what
position yeah that balrog looks so good
yeah this is beautiful
oh damn I know
really really nice
yeah maybe if he was like scaled up a
little bit like I know he has wings
whipping out that are just pretty much
impossible to see maybe if there's like
some backlight on the wings to see more
of that or something
totally yeah it's pretty cash in a
silhouette because I'm sure he's there
I'm sure he's awesome yeah 100 gotta
catch it at the beginning a little bit
of the wing
man dude that fire looks so real God
dang
I love it really good stuff Ben congrats
man congrats on top 100 nice work it's a
movie shot right there yeah seriously
uh Peter Davis
got you next
here we go very different style
oh yeah yeah nice little slow-mo
boom I love this
I would watch this for sure yeah I love
the cartoon smoke there
super clean
uh yeah I mean the boss is so iconic
right I almost wish the hero would pop a
little bit more
especially because the enemies are so
bright
that's the only thing that
small note because to me this is
awesome yeah agreed the cartoon effects
man they add so much
like I love that mix of style they're so
cool
oh
the animation too man props to that
super cool yeah
yeah the landing is nice
yeah with the thrusters in the beginning
too on the feet yeah yeah yeah sick
love it really really nice work Peter
Davis
beautiful congrats
uh we got Jan from Austria what's up
freaking gross
that render quality
that's the stuff that's scary like you
you don't know exactly what it is it's
just nasty I don't want to be around
that thing at all nope yeah he's got
some skull on one of the legs yeah
bikes like it looks like a freaking
spider Scorpion and I'm I'm good on both
of those
yeah yeah
killing one guy is awesome
working creepy really nice render
quality and Lighting on this one got the
film grain going bringing that tree in
the background looks nice
sick
yeah yeah this is
pretty impressive I like it yeah yeah
good stuff Jan congratulations
from Belgium we got Patrick
Lobster battle
yeah that's a boss fight right there 100
played this game
yeah the caustics you got caustics on
the boss you got caustics on the actual
buildings in the background and I'm I
love the buildings man it's like packed
with texture and detail super cool
yeah it's almost like uh
too much detail compared to the rest
kind of I don't know if that was
intentional in the style it works
but there's a little bit of a difference
there yeah like kind of a disconnect
between the
the characters hero and the boss and the
actual background yeah
nice yeah maybe some like
uh I don't know some variation in like
dark red the lighter Reds painted onto
the actual boss or something I don't
know
to add more more of that
detail yeah they'll probably help for
sure yeah
but I love it love the style good stuff
Patrick's good work congrats top 100 we
got
from Bulgaria
cocky
that's very unique yeah right that's
awesome
yeah great render quality too
very simple super super simple but like
really really fun
an execution yeah yeah that's beautiful
it's a good idea the beginning is in
school too yeah
yeah maybe a little like uh from the
hero a quick like
on the attack you know it's a little
slow but that's that's like the only
thing
mm-hmm
yeah real clean really really nice for
sure good stuff
who else we got Natalie
from Canada
oh yes
like the quality on the mouth there
really creepy
that's awesome the gums are just really
nice
you're a little too creepy I know
great use of the of the prompt though
um it's very fun
yeah yeah lighting is super cool yeah
here's the question what is she saying
why is she I think it's fishy yeah yeah
it's gotta be fishy right
no it's uh
it hits or it feels super strong because
you could see
all like everything you're moving yeah I
don't see that water reacting as much
like maybe that
is the only thing that throws me off
Fair yeah maybe the bubbles or something
or I mean this is a tricky shot man I
know it really works
100 yeah and the fish stands out really
nice with the color and everything too
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah good stuff like
Natalie
solid work congrats
all right Kung Fu bro from China is up
next
from one of my favorite movies too
little Stephen Chow action
yeah that's awesome yeah super cool like
vignetted nicely I love that symmetrical
Center frame composition I'm a big fan
of that stuff yeah yeah
super striking
yeah good use of slow-mo there
clouds look good too man
nice attention to detail a lot of work
going on in this one
the dudes legs sticking out from the
from the right side
stuck in the roof that's great good good
details there all right have you ever
seen this movie Kung Fu Hustle
yeah yeah oh man yep one of my favorites
yeah
great work great work Kung Fu bro
solid stuff
all right that's what would you expect
yeah right exactly okay bro
love it
uh from China we got Wario
yeah
I think it's the first one that we see
like a struggle right between
material and boss
another vibe good point buddy yeah yeah
good point so I'm kind of contact yeah
yeah nice color contrast
yeah
the effects are really neat
yeah the Lightning's well done the
bubble the Smash Bros Shield solid
it's almost like the the point of which
we said this a couple times before but
like there's a lot going on
yeah agreed agreed which is hard to
process but
I may be removing even maybe some of the
flags or just try to
would help yeah that's like yeah that's
my only thing it's a little a little
busy
yeah yeah
I love the animation yeah it's well done
it's really well done the struggle the
struggle's real
I hear good stuff Wario congratulations
uh koala is next up
wow
this one's crazy man like
yeah yeah the motion and the animation
is just really nicely done on this one
yep
it's one of those is so much going on
too but the way it's composed and the
lighting helps to separate the elements
of this is pretty clean yeah in a really
really nice way you can tell what's
going on
um it all looks hand animated too
which is awesome Yep everything
really really nice super clean
yep
very uh consistent on the style too
with the effects and everything yeah
nice yeah it's they're doing like
they're mixing the painterly and 3D vibe
in a very very nice way
solid work
yeah this is actually solid good stuff
koala
heck yeah
all right we got Nicholas from France
doing a little 2D 3D action here
oh yeah this definitely feels more in a
composed together yeah yeah it's like 3D
plants 3D like
little
I don't know what you call those like
flower lily things in the foreground
like 3D rocks around the boss and stuff
it feels cool
do you like it
a flag going nice shock wave yeah
foreign
activation in the effects
the lighting that's the only thing even
being 2D and 3D like I wish you would
see more of the
creature in the back because the hero
and the rocks are so bright
got that get that disconnection
yeah yeah that's fair the contrast is a
little bit intense between the two
yeah he's got that kind of sunset almost
almost a sunset on the sky
yeah
yeah it's fair
cool designs yeah I dig the the energy
on this one it's cool
um let's see we got from Germany we got
Vogel up next
oh this is cool
he's showing up with bait for the boss I
love it a little kid
yeah yeah
I love the Shader work here in the
lighting yeah super clean like no noise
whatsoever
drool coming out of the boss's mouth is
a nice touch too
mm-hmm
solid guys I start spinning
candy peppermint
it's one of those things that it's hard
to maintain a style like this right so
when it's well done you gotta appreciate
the trees are super clean yeah beautiful
work yeah 100 percent
it'd be fun to play this game
all right who's next congrats Vogel top
but from Germany we got floor Stan
floristan what up
she's just like slowly back in Hawaii I
was like I don't know about this yeah
yeah
it's a cool design yeah
I love the red trees too on the on the
side or plants yeah they pop out real
nice
see you
it's almost like Shadow of the Colossus
but like uh
Japanese inspired version of it
mm-hmm
yeah this one's fun good good use of the
like volumetrics separating the the hero
in the foreground
totally yep
yeah such a nice
composition like a little bit different
than what we've seen for like the sky
and the colors like it was really good
separation yeah yeah really clean for
sure
they get good stuff
yeah I mean even even the way they're
angling the rocks on the right it's like
they're catching the light and just the
perfect perfect amount it's really good
it has that V frame yeah it's nice
um yeah I see 100 yeah
good stuff Lauren Stan
florston floristen from Germany shout
outs congrats on top 100 uh Tino is next
from Germany as well
Lego Star Wars action for you
yeah yeah
oh man cool yeah
and they get such a Lego fan
the render quality is nice on this one
too
yeah yeah
I like it for sure the only thing maybe
if the shots were because everything is
happening Center on the center maybe if
that explosion happened more towards the
right the right side and
even if the character is more towards
the left like spreading out that that
composition would probably help
yeah yeah agreed agreed
because I love the explosion
yes you know super cool stuff
yeah real nice real clean solid stuff
good work Tino Klein
from Germany congrats on top 100 who do
we got next Who's Next y'all we got
George what's up George from Greece
God damn
ruthless
brutal
yeah good good use of slow-mo the
animation is just wacky man I love it
is confident yeah super confident
super cool hold my beer kind of energy
here for sure
awesome yeah like the freaking wobbly
octopus head this is crazy the wobble in
the beginning is almost like God it
throws you off a little like
everything's realistic yeah it's funny
it's solid stuff real nice lighting too
good good render quality
shout outs George
uh from South Korea
we got Beyond song
Kirby action mm-hmm
insane quality on the Fire
and the illumination on that also like
the the boss and the hero are sidelit
edgelit really nicely they stand out
really nice yeah yeah this is super cool
I love the star too yeah
the fact that you can still see is not
just blown out to White but you can
still see some yellow in there is a nice
touch
yeah for sure
super clean yeah
it's fun I wish Kirby games look like
this that'd be sweet
maybe they do I don't know I don't
really I haven't really played Kirby
games in a very long time
what does that mean like this is how
Graphics are gonna be in
23 or something yeah absolutely
uh who's next we got p p odor
Poland
here we go nice little fantasy battle
smoke creature
yeah very filmic cinematic dude the oh
what a shame the freaking rose on the
bottom left just a pet just a single
pedal just getting taken off of that
thing yeah
protecting the Roses is that what it is
something I don't know
um you know looking at it it looks like
everything is burnt except for that spot
so I think it look it looks like he's
protecting that spot
yeah yeah that's a good idea I like that
yeah maybe a little bit more green on
that spot to sell the story there could
help but
yeah if you've seen the fire like
actually getting spread by his shield as
he's shooting it's kind of like
you know really standing there for a
reason yeah because you don't you don't
get the payoff but the motion is really
good yeah
yeah I saw a nice composition super
scary boss
Peter
yeah those wins are crazy yeah nice
little vortex
um let's see from Russia we got Albert
getting us with the games
I love this man I freaking love this
yeah yeah
all the old school
games coming at you
oh yeah some Kongs and Pac-Man mm-hmm
yeah that's what I do
I agreed yeah I love this blocky kind of
style
um done in a modern way it's just so
much fun
yeah with the the cool lighting
it's pretty on point mm-hmm
yeah yeah 100 percent
great work great work Albert congrats on
top 100 dude
yeah I love this one me too yeah me too
um we got
beeped
from France
oh that's cool
yeah that's a high I feel like the few
where you say let's go that's a hot
that's I feel like that's High Praise
I love the original like more idea
because there's a lot of Storytelling
here yeah yeah that's cool
yeah super cool boss I love it very
unique
scissor
yeah
it's one of uh I don't know we've looked
at a lot of them that has that kind of
backlight striking that separate the
characters
I think this one could use some of that
to make it more
impressive
maybe pushing the lighting a little bit
further yeah you see you see those
highlights in the back background
like the it looks like lights from a
building in the backpack right there the
brightest ones
yeah
and maybe if like the edge light on the
boss was a little bit more of that value
a little bit brighter or something
exactly so you get that cut out with the
rim light which really makes it pop yeah
yeah this one's sick I love it really
nice
all right who's next Who's Next we got
from South Africa
Wick
oh Iron Giant
classic yeah such a good movie if you
guys never seen Iron Giant definitely
check it out
yeah beautiful shot
um
really nice work separating the hero in
the front
with that nice nice sharp lighting
the render quality
yep super clean yeah
I don't know what do you think
like
does this one need a contrast light or
do you think it works as is
um the only thing that to me that
maybe is too much is the the smoke right
because you're seeing it there's some so
much detail
and you've kind of seeing the blobs
I see yeah maybe maybe it feels a little
bit darker you'll get less
uh maybe the sky 2 has a lot of detail
on the sky that was cleaner yeah I don't
know it works it feels like it just gets
a little muddy when it's like too much
of the same Hue yeah yeah Fair
yeah this one's sick I love it
nice nice Center framed
kind of style I'm a big fan of that
stuff
um we got Manuel from Germany
hitting us with this one dude this one's
so good
God dang that's very different yeah
so well done
ah and that Snapback too like
there's a fight here like there's a
clear fight and there's multiple moves
going on you know there's an attack from
the boss there's a counter from the hero
which turns into an attack like that's
so good
yeah yeah
I love that animation on the slow-mo
it's used really well yeah I agreed
the snap to change color
it's cool payoff
yeah
and then the fly there's like a little
fly character in the beginning you
smacks his eyeball out of his head
he gave him the distraction he needed
you know
solid lighting solid Runner quality good
color just everything here is fire in
all cylinders
yeah the render is nice yeah
nice Shader yeah really really good
stuff
Manuel
congrats man top 100
from Sweden
we got Colin shout outs to ya
oh man that's a cool composition for
sure yeah
I love the lighting and the colors here
yep
lots of nice stuff happening
yeah the sword too it like the sword
transforms which
yeah yeah getting ready yeah
yeah all the little like um
little what would you call it uh the
little groupings of light
on the left and the right like the
little Watchtower on the right is cool
the little workstation on the left I
like that a lot
oh yeah some people watching yeah
good stuff
really nice love the color too
yeah this is awesome man good stuff
from Turkey
what you got what you got
I love those effects yeah it's cool yeah
good effects
good effects for sure the light
interaction of the beam on the ground
like blasting the Rocks away it just
sells really nicely
mm-hmm
got some uh some of that demo background
that looks pretty clean yeah what's that
uh I forgot the name of that the like
yeah the like ue5 nanite uh yeah yeah
like Tomb Raider looking thing 100
percent
I love to like the guy if he would have
just kept running like it would have
been chill
you gotta show off a little yeah of
course you know
absolutely
I was sick I love it really good effects
good particle stuff
yeah shout outs man congrats on top
are we good we got bucket Boy Next from
the UK
Tyree bucket boy what you got for us my
friend
oh damn yeah
super cool yeah I love it
totally like a Smash Bros Final Smash
yeah yeah kind of energy
cool he like separates his body his hand
keeps coming at the camera
as his body lags behind he like
separates him into 3D it's really cool
oh yeah you're right
see the parts
it's such a cool effect yeah it works
really well yeah the hand drawn Vibe and
like purple green go in
mm-hmm
they get I like the design too
yeah
we should get more more of that hero
because he looks super cool yeah
that's fun yeah yeah I play this game
it's not
good stuff Tyree bucket boy
from the UK
all right here we go
Colin from the U.S what you got
boom
that guy's fishing what is he doing it's
gonna stick
he has no chance
no he's like crap
it's funny it does look like he's
fishing
yeah I love the love the colors here the
lighting is really nice nice and crispy
with that Setting Sun it's cool
background yeah
nice little slam yeah
and maybe if the boss was a little bit
of a colder like hue
um stand out a little bit more yeah need
that contrast color
yeah fair fair because he does kind of
blend in with the background
and the sky I guess a little bit it's
all kind of like that yeah
I guess he is a mountain maybe I was hit
hitting in the mountain if that's what
you're going for like there's yeah yeah
is it like a rock on top of his like
shoulder
like a mountain maybe then if the hero
was the papa caller
100 yeah good stuff Colin
who's next we got oh we're gonna avoid
metatrox what up meta trucks
damn all right yeah yeah
like a movie seriously
God dang
oh yeah I love the view the VFX here on
point for sure yeah the explosions are
ridiculous
got a big ship in the back coming at you
yeah up top it's nice
yeah he really packed the scene full of
detail here
um and as much as
there is going on I feel like it is
still pretty centered and focused yeah
on these two guys
100 which is really works yeah
yeah it does super clean
hmm
yeah that's awesome great work metatrox
man hats off to you dude
because it really started to see all
these oh these people are fighting and
then immediately just
everybody gets destroyed mm-hmm
yeah the explosions on the side like
really help Focus
everything to the center
down the big guy yeah Silhouettes
Silhouettes the hero for just a second
so nice good stuff matrox
Stephen
solid work congrats on top 100 man all
right we got Drake The One and Only
Drake
wait which Drake
oh the real Drake Drake wanna know Drake
hanukker one and only from the US
PC trouble man that's how he feels to be
effects artists
and yes can't relate absolutely the blue
screen of death
yeah I love the lighting on this one the
top down
top down lighting it just catches all
the details so nicely
this is our it hero
yeah red
it's on the case
yeah really fun
I just love like we saw a similar one
with the uh was it with the N64 or the
SNES
as a robot form like I love the idea of
kind of like technology we we all know
and then doing a robot version of it
it's just really fun
yep super cool
good stuff
the one and only Drake
all right
Nick is next from the US what you got
for us
a battle between mushroom
and rock thing yeah
very colorful saturated painterly
yep
I'll watch this for sure this is cool I
always love like yeah little mushroom
Warriors
can go wrong with that yeah
little characters little like little
Ghibli characters basically
yeah yeah
this reminds me of a game that I'm
blanking on the name of but it's like uh
is it Cora and the like Forest Spirits
or something I don't know if you ever uh
oh is it uh Ori in the forest Spirits
Zoey no not we're in the blind Forest
but it's like it's like if you were to
swipe next it would be the next one
basically
okay yeah
but yeah it has this vibe to it um
so nice
oh yeah Kina that's it Kina in the
forest Spirits or something like that
that's good stuff
rocked on Nick and anywhere also
lighting here is this beautiful it's
really nice yeah yeah it's like that
golden hour
um
just makes everything punch really nice
saturation is really nice
dang it
cool let's see Tom
our boy Tom from the US my goodness
buckle up
oh
what the heck man
it's so cool yeah
rest in peace
yeah seriously
you know do what you can for uh
you know for the rest of the squad here
one one last dive
yeah yeah that the boat breaking is
fantastic man it's super nice
look at that it's almost works perfectly
yeah
this is awesome yeah the way it lights
up here is just in insane
crazy
you also see like when he when he dashes
forward like you see the wind just
swirling behind him
that's awesome are the wind or the just
the water yeah he carries the rain with
him
God dang it helps frame frame the the
action
yeah bands uh-huh
really good stuff
wow good stuff Tom
um from Vietnam
Farm
when
oh
yeah I love that yeah it's just really
well done
such a cool design I know cyan
the orange
yep
it's fun it's it's funny because this
this actually feels like a mid-journey
image to me like but then like
basically made from scratch in 3D
it has that like the colors or something
I don't know the composition
that's great but yeah what a creepy boss
man tank Spider-Man thing oh
really nice solid solid stuff
I'm trying to I'm just absorbing you
know everything that's going on because
there's a face down in there
yeah the face it's got all the shots
going
really good work
solid stuff congrats on that top 100.
see we're we're almost done we got like
10 more or something let's see uh from
Finland we got Benjamin
nice little slow-mo action slow mo
explosion
yep
I love the way that the explosion
affects the environment and knocks the
all the foliage away blows his hat off
oh yeah
sick
yeah I love that explosion looks super
neat yeah
yeah it's definitely like a stylized
kind of look
explosion lights it up real nicely
back some OverWatch yeah 100 100 yeah
if the guy was throwing the maybe if the
guy was more to the right because it
just at the beginning it's hard to tell
like why
it's like throwing her up and then
shooting
yeah yeah I think it is a little like
framed left
yeah heavy I think if you're right if
the boss was maybe where the cactus was
or in between that
yeah he's destroying the the lady more
towards the middle of the screen yeah
there you go maybe that'll help a lot of
good stuff happening I love the the
effects yeah agreed agreed
solidwork Benjamin congrats on top 100
from Finland
uh next up we got Oscar from the UK
oh man yes agreed
just that little turn perfect yeah
yeah it's really nice the colors are
nice like the gravity is cool when the
pigeon slams down all the blueberries
going wild
textures
the thumb prints in there is nice like
using the green bandana on the hero to
separate them from the other blueberries
is nice oh yeah yeah right foreign
super fun I love this yeah dude on the
right here look at these guys do a face
kick you guys like she walks up his own
dude's face like that that's crazy
it's fun I love it I like the the adding
the chickens in the back just to add
contacts to the shapes because it's hard
to tell at first
but yeah yeah no agreed agreed yeah
it's a good note I like this yeah great
work Oscar congrats
we got
John G Geo Wang Shing I'm so sorry I
butchered that
hmm
pile of design the design of that boss
and like the texturing and lighting is
just so sick
yeah that background yeah I mean it's
fun
really helps with the separation there
it's cool
especially
yeah there's a lot there's a lot and it
still works it's a very you know the
elements are kind of combined together
pretty sweet yeah yeah I agreed the blue
certainly helps the laser draw the eye
and nice touch on like the laser cutting
through the dust in the beginning
it's not just one solid laser line it's
kind of broken up
I like that
really nice work
congrats top 100 baby moving on
we have a handful more here
kirubel kirubel from Ethiopia
let's go yeah good slide
in charge yeah
I love that effect it was different from
what we've seen from the dash
[Music]
I like the striped wavy
it's cool
um
yeah this one's real simple very focused
uh and totally works for it
yeah
maybe okay yeah the light of the
lighting is sick the top down is good I
was thinking though the red you see the
under light on the red in the background
maybe like if that was a little bit
creeping up a little bit more to the
halfway point of the background would
help
it's like a secondary kind of color
maybe
this one's fun
yeah that's cool it's one of those I
want to see what happens next I know
everything works I know I want that
payoff so bad
sweet
what else what else like CarX light
likes knocka123 as you go on Discord
from Finland
ah yes
straight from hyper light Drifter good
shout out so disaster piece is doing the
the music for the top 100
um which comes out next week so this is
a nice little little shout out to
disaster piece demand that's cool yeah
is that from a music video or what
um this scene here yeah it's from a game
called hyper light Drifter
oh okay yeah it's one of my favorite
games of all time it's like the game
itself is incredible the art is
incredible
um and the soundtrack is like top for
the best it's just the best
um it's like a dark
Zelda almost with like really
uh skill based kind of
uh what do you call it gameplay
mechanics he plays like this ninja guy
oh I see I pretty much
so good
but yeah anyway the render's cool too
yeah really nice here good good lighting
good colors
good interpretation
super sick great work
all right guys we've got like six more
here
and then we're gonna announce them
winners
loik from France let's see what you got
you got a slide for us nice little slide
oh wait
yeah there's more
nice
it's cool yeah nice animation
almost has like a storybook fantasy kind
of style to it with the lighting yeah
and
definitely does
yeah and the slow-mo like uh
you could use a slow-mo there always
down for a nice slide
thank you uh
super cool yeah good stuff
congrats loik
all right a few more here Noah
oh another little puppet scissor cut
what's with the puppets made
a few of those just help we're all held
back you know trying to be set free yeah
yeah
this is nice I think that his hand kind
of covers the boss a little
yeah yeah the face of help because it's
a cool design
yeah a face exhaust
yeah it's fun
nice little Spotlight down the center
there
great lady
uh the callers too like really makes the
hero pop on the little
puppet agreed yeah definitely
nice little contrast with the with the
candles too good stuff super solid yeah
beautiful
uh lee who from Vietnam
hit list with the stylized uh yeah yeah
I'm a fan
I love this
yep
I'd play the heck out of this man
yeah
me too this is beautiful
it would have been nice to have a bigger
explode
set up and there's like
right at the end there
with the effects man like that Sword and
the trail yeah awesome all about it yeah
the Lightning's sick the colors the
green blue sick
yeah yeah it's really nice
a bit weirdly or lay like who
um
yukai Graphics from China
hitting us with this one
yeah
yeah the lighting's great picking up all
that detail on the boss
yep yep
something with that definitely the top
light on the boss like makes you feel
super impressive
little Shield effect on the hero yeah
super nice very well done all the moving
pieces to the cables and like even the
stuff on the side is moving with the
boss which is really really well done
yeah that's awesome yeah love it love it
do you ever play um stray the cat game
you remember that one yeah yeah I play
that yeah it kind of reminds me of that
a little bit one of the boss fights in
that one it's cool
they have some really nice robots in
that game dude that game was so good
that was like one of my favorite games
uh two more here guys two more you Chen
with the underwater
oh that's different yeah yeah
really cool creature design it's fun
great idea yeah
damn that blood
yeah
it's huge I know it's massive
yeah super sick love the subsurface on
the boss is nice
yep
congrats you Chen top 100 we are making
it to our last one guys here we go
who's it gonna be
and they're going to be from Poland and
their name is going to be Leon
and it's going to be this render right
here
nice yeah I love it
yeah yeah that that
thunderstorm that lighting's cool yeah
catching the rain nicely
it did a good job with like
the rain actually looking like streaks
when we're in real time but when we go
in slow-mo they go down to actual little
like droplets like that it's a nice
touch
yeah yeah good call
nice destruction too
super cinematic
yeah yeah
it'd be awesome to like see his hand to
like follow through was that yeah it's
like a bazooka
headshot yeah it's a freaking Corkscrew
just coming through yeah like a hand up
on like the tower would have been nice
smashing one of those
yeah yeah
awesome super impressive this is cool
yeah so that's that's the top 100 for
you guys
um
100 so let's we'll do um
I'll go ahead and play them all for you
guys
here
we'll just do one final recap
and kind of take a look at everything
yeah this is fun it's the fun part yeah
here we go
ah yeah so
as I've mentioned we're doing the top
100 Montage coming out
next week next Saturday with the custom
soundtrack by disasterpiece
um so I'll be putting all of these
renders in order to the music you guys
might get a nice little music video
going but um really congratulations to
all you guys who submitted to this thing
you know a lot of you is your first time
um
for a lot of others you guys are
returning and you guys kill it every
time I just want to say a big
congratulations to you all
um
and Raph man thank you so much for for
judging with us dude uh
I mean this is incredible man props to
all of you guys it's crazy
just to see like how yeah how how
impressive these are
insane there's a super talented yeah in
a month's time too it's crazy absolutely
crazy
yeah
so we have our top five
um we're gonna reveal them here in a
second
um
because that's what that's what it comes
down to guys that's what it comes down
to these top five here so let me go over
the prizes one more time so first off to
all of you guys who have your art here
in the top 100 y'all are getting
um a caft.com t-shirt code so you guys
go to their website pick a shirt they'll
send it to you
um for fifth place all the way up to
first place kaft is also giving out 200
bucks
um to their site for all of you guys for
all the top five that we're gonna
announce here in a second
from there um let's see we got Jenga
effects also giving out five codes
um to their entire license the Ember gen
or the the Jenga FX license Perpetual
Suite so you get everything
um for free for every forever basically
so let's start with amberjan go into
their liquid gen and then geogen when it
comes out later
um what else we got
um we got kit bash 3D hooking you guys
up as well with uh with their cargo
subscriptions you guys get three months
to Cargo as well for all of all of uh
one through five
um so that's basically access to all of
their assets instead of having to buy
individual packs super helpful
um what else third place
you're getting Rococo Mo cap gloves
coming at you
um second place is getting a smart suit
Pro 2 and first place is getting the
full performance capture bundle with the
gloves the suit face cap and everything
so lots lots of fun stuff to give out
here
um
RAF shall we get into it shall we
announce the the top five here we
feeling good
let's do it man all right I'm just
enjoying this like watching it again
it's so cool to see them all together
I know dude yeah yeah with the music too
it's like uh it really really comes
together it's a lot of work too because
it's like you know making eight and a
half minutes worth of music and then
having it sound uh
you know have it change the vibe every
couple minutes essentially it's making
like three songs for a crazy music video
for all your guys's hard work so
I don't think I've ever told you this
but the first one I saw from your your
channel the video was like the walking
challenge the side one like this the
side one yeah yeah when I saw that like
what the hell like who were making these
things this is so cool
so Props to you and the community man
this stuff is amazing yeah I mean it's
grown like crazy like I didn't really
expect it um and of course it's just all
the community
um putting in their hard work and
you know we want to try and put out like
a positive vibe and uh
get that spark going for the community
and and just keep the energy going
because uh you know it's tough It's
sometimes it's tough to find the spark
um
I don't know have you ever gone through
burnout Raph have you dealt with that
before uh it always kind of comes and
goes yeah I think it usually sometimes
is good to take breaks but then I feel
like you also have to force yourself to
just get going again start doing stuff
because once you're in the Groove and
you're doing something that's like fun
then he kind of goes away from my
experience I feel like the challenge is
just to get get going
yeah get the ball rolling yeah how do
you feel about it
um for me like I've talked about it here
on the channel a couple times but like I
I feel like I burn out like once once a
year at the end of the year where I just
feel like I can't do anything
um and I think this year is the gonna be
the first year where I don't burn out
which is amazing and I think that's huge
um
and yeah I mean honestly it's taking a
break and stepping aside and like
um getting to the point where you can
create for fun as opposing to create for
a deadline
um and like the less pressure you can
kind of put behind it at least in my
experience like
uh you know you need those four fun
projects that that are low stakes you
know
um yeah yeah
sometimes I just
learning something is also good because
you often pressure ourselves to
like finish a project but if you just
get to like oh I'm gonna learn something
new that usually helps for me like I'm
just kind of focusing on following a
tutorial or not even thinking so much on
the creative space is just more of
execution and like oh I just do this and
uh get you going do something cool
yeah like an experimentation kind of
thing versus like a final
yeah yeah totally yeah that's how you
grow yeah yeah just for yourself not
even worrying about posting or anything
dude I think that's so important
honestly what you just said
um
being able to do art for yourself that
doesn't have to be posted it doesn't
have to be liked
um doesn't have to go viral just doing
something for yourself that's fun is
I think that's the fuel that keeps us
going for sure
all right y'all I think it's about time
let's announce these top five
let's get right into it all right so
coming in fifth place it's gonna be none
of these I promise let me zoom in here
let me get let me get set
here we go
I'll get right up to the line here
coming in fifth place
from Germany
we have
Robin Patelco
it's not this one I'm sorry
there we go bam Robin
shout outs to you congratulations on top
five
fifth place baby with this beautiful
render we love your color we love your
lighting we love your VFX the
simulations the use of slo-mo it's
you're firing in all cylinders man
really well done really really well done
ref you have anything to say about uh
about Robin's here fifth place oh yeah
yeah are you you hit on a lot of the the
good things everything is done really
well animation composition color
lighting this is spot on so
yeah congrats man this is awesome good
animation super sick congratulations
Robin I'll be in touch with you I'll be
in touch
all right and the next one coming up in
fourth place
um me and RAF we really love this one uh
and uh I know you guys will too this is
a great one this is this is from
the US an artist from the US
and uh he goes by the name of
metatrox congratulations dude
congratulations metatrox fourth place
dude he killed it
absolutely killed it with this one man
what a wonderful piece you put together
so much detail here yeah go ahead rap
no that's a sick shot I mean there's a
lot going on and I think the
storytelling is there
effects like movie quality this is
impressive that's me yeah 100 percent
good work metatrox he's been on the
server for for years
um and I think this is his first win so
he's been talking these challenges yeah
for a very long time so metatrox
seriously dude congratulations to you
I'm super proud of you man uh I'll be in
touch for sure
all right
working our way up we got third place
coming up who's it gonna be it's gonna
be an artist from Germany
um
they put something together uh that blew
some Minds here so let's just get right
to it congratulations Manuel
Manuel Peter
with this render here man you're killing
it firing on all cylinders the animation
here is super sick
like the technical
the technical side is incredible loving
the colors the lighting the render
quality dude super fun
as one of those that really stand out
for being just unique
and fun and good storytelling
technically is pretty impressive
absolutely yeah yeah congratulations yay
good stuff Manuel
all right
and we get down to it we get down to it
second place
second place of the boss fight 3D
Community challenge goes to an artist
from China
and they go by the name of koala
congratulations koala
yes we love it man the painterly style
the animation the hand animation
everything pops it flows it just works
super beautiful great great work
congratulations to you koala congrats
man Lots going on really well balance
shot super cool yeah well executed very
very well executed
all right y'all
and it comes down to it
the one the only the winner
of the 3D Community challenge
taking it down taking the boss down
is
a brazilian-based artist
shout outs
and he goes by the name of Fabricio
my goodness Fabricio you did it again my
friend congratulations to you
for first place my God killing it with
this animation
Wow have he won before
yeah yeah and I just want to clarify I
did not know he was Brazilian I've had
on my side so people think this is uh
not a not a real thing this is no this
shot is incredible and animation's
beautiful
composition character design like hits
checks on all the boxes so yeah awesome
yup 100 this was our one so basically
what we did was did a blind
a blind top five and when we compared
this was both our top one
um so congratulations Fabricio man
amazing amazing work you killed it from
modeling custom modeling this guy to
doing everything here in Unreal Engine
like congratulations
uh the art it stands out dude it really
does congratulations
and so the rest of you guys the top 100
man and all of all of you who entered
these uh this challenge all 2 880 of you
I'm very very impressed thank you so
much for all the hard work
um
hats off man hats off
yeah I'm sure you've said this many
times before but it's really hard to
pick top 10 top five top 100 like it's a
tough thing because there's so many good
good ones and there's you could
obviously uh explain why other ones
would be in the top 10 or top five or
you know even top one but I mean this is
about more of
you know putting the work together so
kudos to all you guys and this stuff is
amazing yeah absolutely it's it really
is um at the end of the day it's about
having fun and participating in
something completing a project and all
of you guys did that so seriously huge
congrats congratulations to you guys
um and yeah it is tough you're right
Raph it is tough because like picking
the top 100 is it's all very subjective
and you do your best to pull that
together and of course the top five is
is very subjective as well so
um but you know we you know we do our
best here and and we pull based off of
our taste here
um the top five and the top 100 so
congratulations to you
um if you guys have any questions
for for RAF maybe we take like I don't
know just five minutes is that is that
cool with your app or you need to bounce
I'm good I'm good so if you guys have
any questions for Raph hit me with a app
Punisher in the chat and we'll answer
well I'll you know curate some and throw
them to
to wrap here for you guys
if not that's all cool too you guys
love all you guys
let's see I'll go ahead and loop this
for y'all
let's see
so cool man yeah
yeah
how'd you come up with the idea I'm
curious now yes
Yeah so basically basically what we did
here
um is
when I I so I started my channel in 2006
and
so it's almost been God dang it's been
like 16 17 years
and I took a long break I took like a
six year Break
um and this was when I was working at
other companies
and I always felt like I felt bad
um
like
leaving my channel behind
and that always kind of that always kind
of got in my mind I was like man I
should really be continuing to build
this
and um
it wasn't until like three years ago
three and a half years ago where I was
like you know what I'm just gonna
live stream VFX 3D stuff on the weekend
and I did that every Saturday I started
doing it every Saturday while I was
working at corridor
and
people watched people started joining me
they they hopped in and you know we kind
of rebooted the channel together and it
got to the point where like
the art I was making on stream
we were doing like you know let's see if
I can make something by the end of the
stream and people were like oh I want to
do that too so we got to the point where
like
we started doing weekly challenges
you know like inktober right
where it's like uh oh you get a prompt
every day for for every day in October
it's like that but instead for 3D so you
get a prompt every week and we started
doing those and it could have been
anything from like black and white to
um you know to uh astronaut to whatever
you know anything
and then I wanted to do something that
like really in integrated the community
in a larger sense in like a storytelling
sense where we can create something
together right so so you know
basically put together this kind of like
template style
um Vibe here
and I love the whole like match cut
there's this oh there's this like uh are
you a Radiohead fan by chance
uh somewhat yeah so yeah yeah it's Hit
or Miss sometimes
um but they have this they have this
music video called everything in its
right place and it's one of the it's an
incredible music video and it has like a
character going through this story and
it's like cutting between the character
and like all these moments in life and
it tells this incredible story I'm like
wow that's so cool so we kind of like
you know kind of did something similar
and um
and got to the point where I was like
you know like I want to mix it up people
really like it so let's mix it up every
time we do this so every time we do one
of these challenges we try and do uh
something different so this one yeah
this one was boss fight that's what it
came down to
I
love it
all right guys let's take a look let's
take a look at the chat
see let's switch over
just as for Kraken I know Kraken was
great Kraken was great you know it was
top it was top ten that's for sure for
sure man yeah that was a super good one
yeah
all right let's see
all right I think elgin's got a question
I was wondering when the next challenge
is that's gonna be in February
let's see
all right uh all right Ralph we got a
question for you is this from Nick
grossfeld
your career is pretty massive you've
worked on a lot but in the looking back
on everything do you have a favorite
project that you worked on and why was
that a favorite project for you
uh man
every time there's a first
it's kind of your favorite then you kind
of get used to it I'm sure you've been
through this before like when you do
like your first
commercial it's like oh I'm watching
this on like whatever it is and you have
that hype and it kind of goes away once
you start doing more commercials be like
ah I don't want to do this anymore so
every time like I've jumped around to
different types of projects I'm like
okay this is one of my favorite things
um on like career side I guess like God
of War like it's been the last decade
just working on those
uh so that has been probably the most
rewarding involved project that I've
been you know a part of from the
beginning you know to the end and being
able to direct has been
really rewarding yeah
you guys won game of the year for for
God of War which is insane and you were
nominated for Game of the Year again for
the other one that you guys did so so
that's insane
yeah yeah thank you man in Spain is you
know extreme Challenge to do to make
those so
it's been fun yeah yeah what I'm working
on now I think is probably
more exciting but it's always like that
you you always the new thing should
excite you to keep going so yeah 100 man
yeah keep it up keep it up so we got
Macario asking a solid this one's a good
one he says when's the last time you
watched a tutorial from start to finish
whoa great question uh I'm I'm finally
working on unreal now and it's been like
a
a long term a long thing for me right
like long time coming just because we've
worked on proprietary engine uh over at
Sony and I've got really good at that
we're now transitioning to Unreal has
been uh super fun
so that has been
uh kind of a learning curve for me but
um it's been awesome like that I mean I
wish I would have worked in a real for
you know for a long time it's some
things are really easy some things not
that much uh yeah but it's super cool
but I've been watching tutorials
obviously watching your channel uh I had
some cool stuff here you know uh William
Foshay
on he's a yeah that guy's incredible man
so good yeah it's one of the best
tutorials
yeah I love that I love the timing and
you know the calm aspect of the things
yeah he's got a good vibe going but yeah
unreal's tough man it's like a lot of
the steepest learning curve it's
probably one of the hardest programs
I've ever learned so
um some things that you just like why so
I know like I just I guess evolved
through years and being working on a
proprietary engine uh makes you
more specialist on the types of games
that we make so like it's almost catered
to certain things that we do where
unreal like serves a lot of different
clients right so there's a lot of
different
uh tools yeah so it's been it's been a
cool cool uh learning curve for me
watching a lot of tutorials so
yeah fun stuff yeah
we got another question from darshan Raj
um and he he's asking what's the top
three things that make a good render
um is it the lighting the modeling the
background the story like of course all
these things come together but like your
first impression when you see a first
impression what are the three things
that are usually like
um working together to give you a very
nice pleasing kind of look at the end
nice yeah I can probably speak to you
know even some of the things that I do
but I try to look at primary secondary
tertiary like a lot of people go into
the detail of things and just throw a
lot of stuff at it and it's very easy to
do that in unreal I guess because you're
either working with libraries or just
very easy to kind of throw stuff at it
when you're doing character art for
example is
um yeah working zbrush uh very easy to
add details but I try to like really
step back and really look at primary
forms primary colors composition because
if that's on point and it's working like
very simple and you see and it's
pleasing and it works adding the
secondary edit the tertiary is more of a
time consuming thing so to me it's more
especially over the years with my own
projects like I've tried to reduce the
amount of complexity complexity uh and
then focus on you know either Anatomy or
you know just making sure it's well
polished but taking a step back and
looking at the primary forms and shapes
and colors is probably the more
important thing
yeah so you get your basic building
blocks your your the most basic brush
Strokes to look as good as possible and
you kind of detail in from there is what
you're saying yeah yeah design is good
composition is good if everything is
working at that point then that's the
most difficult part I think guess
getting to that point of like okay this
is good as a sketch it's it's it works
then you add the details and you should
be good
so Andrea is saying did you do live
streams in the past Raph
I didn't have some yeah on YouTube you
got some fans here man you got some fans
here
I wish I would go back with those
um maybe maybe in the future
so
um let's see uh
I'm trying to get one more
we'll get one more and we'll let you go
let's see
all right
so I was I saw this from one of you guys
um they want to know how you got into 3D
what was the first thing who was the
person that did it like what did you see
that was like I'm gonna mess with this
I'm gonna see what's up
oh man
you guys weren't
uh around back then I'm just gonna start
with the old man uh conversations book
to me uh it was definitely we went
through like the flash animations kind
of era right we had like all the
websites and we had a lot of just 2D
animations and that's how I got started
into
trying things in the computer and then I
went into 3ds Max back then and we
didn't even have like tutorials or
YouTube didn't exist right so it's kind
of more learning in uh forums
um but this is 20 years ago 20 plus
years ago
and then most of the softwares like a
lot of poly uh by poly modeling and I
started getting into the whole uh you
know old school kind of processes which
is very important right even to this day
even though things are kind of changing
but as a production artist like I went
through all the phases of like animation
and like uh a lot of it's self-taught
but uh I started working like I
mentioned I've worked started working
really young I was lucky enough to do
that because I learned at the job and I
really recommend people to just get that
experience when they're trying to get
started because you can try to do a lot
of things by yourself but you you're
always going to be scared of like
production if you don't if you haven't
been through it so just kind of try to
get that experience early on it's super
important but that's how I got started
and then I moved into uh the modeling
side of things when zbrush came out
uh start doing a lot of freelance for
cinematics building characters started
to get involved in animation when I
first got into games that's when I might
kind of knowledge
I could use a lot of those the knowledge
because making games is a lot about
figuring out things as you go
um and it has been super fun but that's
kind of a short long story short
heck yeah dude thank you so much again
we'll let you go here but man
really that was fun thank you for doing
this uh it's a pleasure to have you best
of luck man working uh at Netflix on on
your new game the new IP that's really
really exciting we all can't wait to
play it man we're all rooting for you
um very inspirational to have you here
so thank you thank you thank you so much
appreciate it man hey congrats on the
Channel with all the challenges I know
I've tried to do some myself because I
know how important this is for people
I I mean I have to I have to do it again
not not me sorry not me doing a
challenge but like I have my own
challenge yeah yeah where can people
find those by chance um because I think
a lot of people here would enjoy doing
those I was always running on Instagram
uh and then just like through Discord
but I have to pick them back up it's
been a couple years since we've done one
yeah uh but those are always super fun
so I'll probably you know
you know pick them back up but again
it's important for the community I know
people always vibe off of those and if
we can Inspire some people to get
started that's what's you know that's
the whole reason behind doing these
things so I appreciate what you're doing
thank you for having me awesome
dude right back at you dude thank you so
much thank you thank you for your time
um to uh BRB here and uh I'll see you
back here in a couple minutes
um and uh we'll hang out for a few but
RAF thank you have a good one dude
thank you see you guys
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
what's up guys
I see y'all in chat you're like what the
heck
without the cracking when at the
cracking
objective y'all come on now
come on I don't do this alone right you
know that's why we have judges is to try
and get as much going as possible
um
I'd say hats off to the winners great
job guys uh we had we had a top ten we
had a top 12.
and it's really hard it's really hard uh
picking these so
you know
congrats to the winners that's all I
gotta say I know I know some of you guys
feel different but that's okay it's
subjective it's all good it's all good
um
ah man that was tough that was tough
always always tough man seriously but
it's a good time I'm really excited to
to do the top 100 get the disaster piece
custom music going I'm hanging out with
you guys for the next 10 minutes
um we can hang out here if you have any
questions for me please let me know
Edge what's up Edge says what if Clint
since every time
but this was the best competition yet
mind-blowing top 100 this time honored
to be among all these legendary
submissions thank you edge I appreciate
it man
really solid really really solid
oh man
um tasawara
you're asking can you see mine
's like not really done I'm gonna be
honest with you guys
I kind of didn't I didn't make it
um it was
it was tough I'm trying not to be too
hard on myself for not completing the
art
because I know I'm like obviously
running a YouTube channel I spent four
weeks streaming the art of my
of my art and everything
and I am at the very end if I can finish
it this week
or even you know finish it when I get
back I'm going to to camp mograph in
Colorado
um that would be ideal because I don't
want to like waste the time
for me it's like an experiment on style
and having fun with the art I should
really finish it
I think it just comes down to time for
me because basically I have to wrap out
this stuff I have to wrap out the all
renders I go to Colorado I come back I
have to finish other videos
so it's just a lot it's a lot on my
plate
um
but yeah I feel a certain way about it
most definitely
um but try not to get too down about it
that's for sure
um oh Sean I'll have the winners in the
description of this video here once we
sign off so you guys can check them out
check out their art stations and all
that stuff and also along with the top
100 including the all-renders there's
gonna be like a a Google sheet of all of
the artists names the ones that chose to
not be anonymous as well as where you
can find them so you can check out all
their work and whatnot
let's see let's see
all right let the top 100 run in the
background sure it went up
let's see
yeah there we go that works
foreign
you're asking if there's a way you can
get your art acknowledged if you didn't
get the top 100 and I'd say the best I
mean that's why we have the all renders
Montage so to you guys who submitted if
this is your first time doing this
then you know that we put all the
renders together I'm sorry that you
wouldn't know but basically we put all
the renders together at the end there's
2880 submissions and those will all be
packaged together with music and
everything
um in a multi-hour long video that'll go
up on I believe it's on the scroll on
the bottom here but I believe it's
September yep September 17th is when the
all renders Montage goes out and as long
as you submitted properly without any uh
like missing uh an extreme amount of
missing frames or you know it's in like
48 fps or something as long as you
follow the rules on that sense all of
your renders there will be in the all
renders montage
so the renders at the top of the stream
you said there was a bunch of awesome
ones during the the five minute
countdown so those were ones that made
like uh what we did Me Myself and the
moderators we go through all 2880 and we
pull
um like 200 renders we go through and we
just pull you know we want to go we're
aiming for a number that's a little bit
larger than the top 100 because it's a
lot easier to kind of like chisel down
to top 100 than it is to have to go back
through everything to pull another 10.
so we'll pull 200 or so I think we had
like 208 and we basically pulled the top
100 from those 208 selects and the ones
that you find in the uh like the stream
startup when we're waiting for the
stream to come on the countdown that's
the others that were like they were
pulled as selects but they just barely
didn't make it into the top 100
um
but they're still incredible renders
like that it's so that's the hardest
part about this is like
just because we're choosing top 100 and
winners
like
there's the positive and the negative
way to think about it
and
I you know it every everyone's everyone
is on their own Journey everyone's art
is where is their best that they can
possibly do so to say to someone that
their best isn't good enough that's not
the vibe that we're trying to give out
at all
um I really I want I just want to praise
as many of these renders as possible
let's go through that again
this was like a few hours three hours
four hours on top 100 like it would take
freaking decades to do all 2 880.
yeah man that was intense that was an
intense challenge I hope you guys
enjoyed yourself
um
I hope you guys learned a lot along the
way and I know that you know speaking
for myself I I didn't finish my art
and
I still had fun and I still learned it
up learned a lot and I have a lot of
goals have from having
gone through the process
and now looking to the future I have a
bunch of things that I want to do I want
to experiment with like different
cartoony Styles and whatnot I think it's
really fun so there's lots of positive
takeaways and I think especially after
this what I would do if you guys are
serious about it only if you're serious
about this
what I would do is
ask yourself a couple questions uh like
a post-mortem almost like
how the challenge was for you how the
experience was for you what you took
away from it what are the positive
takeaways from it
um and how it helped you for the future
um and essentially kind of review the
last month and ask yourself what you
learned
um whether you had fun or not whether it
was a positive thing for you or not and
if it was then I consider you to
continue
um and to come back again for more
challenges because for me
like what really gets me excited and the
spark going is a challenge I don't know
why maybe it's because I love video
games so much but
for me it's that challenge that that
draws me and inspires me to do things
and when I'm doing it with my peers with
with other people that's very very
helpful so
one of you has a question
um
that you work in Game Dev what kind of
Unreal Engine tutorials would I
recommend
so you if you look at William Foshay
that's William it's pronounced or it's
spelled like foucher
f-a-u-c-h-e-r uh you check him out he
has incredible tutorials William foucher
or William Foshay
um Winbush also has a lot of good ones
w-i-n-b-u-s-h Winbush I'm not gonna lie
I'll toot my own horn I got some good
Unreal Engine tutorials as well
um on here on this channel
so I'd say between those three I'm sure
there's a handful of others other people
out there but those are like the main
ones for me that I go to
um super solid unreal tutorials there
there's also prismatica Dev prismatica
Dev
and he has a lot of great like
five ten minute tutorials on what
specific nodes do in the material
Builder inside of Unreal Engine and he
he really knows the technical side of
unreal so he breaks down all these
individual nodes and how to use them and
how they're used in a game sense so
prismatica Dev is a great resource as
well
and yes I'm a bounce here right after
this but yes the next challenge is going
to be in February I don't know what the
challenge is going to be hopefully
something different than what we've done
before we'll see maybe we'll loop back
and we'll try and do something that uh
that you all really loved doing I don't
know we're gonna figure it out we have a
lot of a lot of convert conversing to to
do here before then uh but yeah tons of
work goes into these things so
we start working like a month and a half
in advance so that we can figure out
what the best prompt is and then figure
out the best way to facilitate that
challenge myself and the moderators on
the Discord server so
yeah good stuff thank you all for the
super chats I I may have missed a couple
of you guys uh apologies Jim Rice I see
a
um you say thanks for making the
challenges do your favorite thing on
YouTube dude that's that means a whole
lot to me thank you so much I really
appreciate it
um super sick super sick
um
how can you get started working off of
uh living off of your skills
um
that I got from years of hobby work
so for me personally I say if you
continue to do what you love
and you put it out there people will
come at you
um
I I think that is that is very true in
my experience in my experience that is
true
um specifically how that's done I would
say integrate yourself in the community
make friends in the community
um
it's been a minute since I've done
freelance uh like VFX or freelance 3D
but in this sense by making YouTube
videos by continuing to do all this
stuff
um you know people will reach out
through a business email they'll want to
collaborate they'll want to work on
something
um they'll want to
you know pay me to advertise Etc et
cetera
so
if you have an Avenue for people to
reach out to you that's also another tip
is make it easy for people to reach out
to you
um and keep doing what you love and that
is going to go very very far I promise
but y'all I think that's it
I thank you guys thank you so much I
hope you all have a fantastic weekend
congratulations to the winners
congratulations to the top 100 and
really congratulations to every single
one of you guys who participated all 2
880 of you into the people who didn't
quite make that deadline you should also
be proud of yourself
for taking on the challenge getting as
far as you did I hope you had a fun time
I hope you learned a lot
and uh what else what are we gonna do um
next weekend top 100 Montage with
awesome music from disasterpiece that's
coming out next weekend the following
weekend September 17th is the all
renders Montage all the renders all 2
880 strung up together
categorized nicely
um after that
I'll be taking a little break
and at the end of September I'm gonna
have some fun uh fun photo scanning
video for you guys so definitely look
forward to that we're gonna do like a
mini mini photo scanning weekly
challenge thing on Discord it's gonna be
fun so if you guys aren't subscribed to
the channel definitely subscribe don't
miss anything that comes out I'll be
seeing you guys over the next two weeks
with the montages end of September
um with the fun new video photo scanning
and then from there we got a couple more
videos to wrap out the year and then I'm
gonna be chilling so guys thank you so
much
have a good one have a solid weekend
I'll catch you later peace out y'all
later
[Music]